you
.
Good afternoon, everyone.
It is Thursday, April 23rd,
2026, and this meeting of the
Huntsville City Council is
called to order.
We are met in the chambers of
the Huntsville City Council in
Huntsville, Alabama, and all
councilmembers are present.
We welcome everyone who is
joining us here in the chambers
and also those who are joining
us on our many streaming
practice with an indication given by one of our Huntsville police chaplains, Dr. Sonny
Hatcher, which will be followed by the Pledge of Allegiance, which will be led by Councilmember
John Meredith. All who would like to join us in the prayer and invocation, please, or
the invocation and pledge, please stand.
Let us pray. Heavenly Father, we thank you for bringing us here together tonight. Your
word reminds us that though we are many members, we are one body, each with a purpose, each
needed. Lord, let unity be present in this chamber on tonight. God, every decision with
wisdom, respect, and compassion for one another and for those represented. We ask that you
watch over our military and our first responders, protecting them as they serve. Bless everyone
here and under the sound of my voice. And when we leave this place tonight, grant us
safe travel back home under your continued covering, allowing each of us to reach our
destinations and find them better than when we left. In Jesus' name, amen.
Thank you, Dr. Hatcher. Thank you, Councilmember Meredith. We have a lot of guests joining
us tonight. We welcome you and we will be introducing you shortly. We will move on to
the approval of the agenda. Councilmembers, item 10C has been withdrawn at the request
of the sponsor. Are there any other changes that need to be made to the agenda? Hearing
none, is there a motion to approve the agenda? Motion for Mr. Little, second for Mr. Kling.
All in favor, please indicate. Aye. Opposed? The agenda is approved. Councilmembers, you
also have the minutes of the regular meeting of the City Council held on April 9, 2026
in front of you. Are there any changes or additions to be made to those minutes? Hearing
none, the minutes will stand approved. We have a couple of recognitions from our Mayor.
This is like our favorite part of the meeting. We'll get to recognize really good work that's
being done. So we'll start with 5A, a proclamation declaring April 2026 as Fair Housing Month.
Mayor Battle. Thank you, Madam President and Council. If I could ask Alan Mooseney to come
forward. He is our building, our inspections director, and he, well, wait, you're going
to come in a minute, Alan. I'm going to get Scott Irwin to come forward right now and
we're going to talk about fair housing. He's got buildings. Okay. Scott, have you got some
people with you? I do. Thank you, Mayor Battle. So a couple of remarks. So the Fair Housing
Act was designed to ensure that every person, regardless of their background, family status,
or physical ability, has the freedom to find a home and a neighborhood that meets their
needs and aspirations. Fair housing is the heart of a vibrant and healthy city. As we
recognize this month of April as Fair Housing Month, we celebrate the progress we have made
together and the inclusive future we are continuing to build. I'd like to invite representatives
from the Huntsville Area Association of Realtors down tonight. So Ms. Regina Mitchell, the President,
and then Mr. Tim Brown, which is the board member and the government affairs chairperson.
Ms. Lorraine Cordule, which is the treasurer of the Huntsville Area Association of Realtors.
And also Ms. Sharita Whitehead, which is a member of the North Alabama Black Realtors
Association. So it's partners like these great organizations that allow us to continue to
expand and enforce and make sure that fair housing is an opportunity and a right within
the city of Huntsville. So Mayor Bell, you want to give some comments about the proclamation
itself? The proclamation hits pretty much what Scott was just talking about. It talks
about the anniversary of the signing of the National Fair Housing Act, which was done
in 1968, and the city supports the efforts of the federal government and the state of
Alabama to assure equal access to housing opportunities. And whereas the city of Huntsville
supports programs that will educate the public concerning their rights to equal housing opportunities
to participate in efforts with other organizations. Now therefore, I, Tommy Battle, Mayor of the
city of Huntsville, do hereby declare April 2026 as Fair Housing Month in the city of
Huntsville. Guys, thank you all so much for the work that you do day by day by day. And
y'all are kind of the tip of the spear in this. So I present this proclamation to y'all.
Thank you. Thank you, Mr. Earl and Mayor Battle and the council for the advancement in fair
housing in our area. The city commits to equity in housing, ensuring that our neighbors remain
a place where everyone, regardless of their demographics, has an opportunity to thrive.
Realtors do more than just sell homes. We are neighbors invested in the city's integrity
and we couldn't be more grateful to have a partnership of our local leaders at the Huntsville
Area Association of Realtors. We look forward to working alongside of the city to identify
and eliminate any remaining barriers to fair housing. The Realtor Association will continue
to educate its members and work with our partners at the city towards an equitable future to
all. Thank you so much. Thank you. Thank y'all so much and thank you for your support. Thank
you. Okay, the next item on the agenda is a five B a proclamation declaring May 2026
as building safety month. Now I'll have Alan Mooseney come up to talk to us and talk to
us a little bit about building safety month and why we do building safety month. I could
tell I had the wrong proclamation at the wrong time when I saw the deer in headlights look
in your eyes there. Yes. Thank you mayor. Good evening everyone. I want to kind of do
a summary of what building safety month is but and we recognize building safety month
this May to join in international effort of dedication to one essential idea. The places
we live, work and gather must be safe, resilient and built for the future. Building safety
month reminds us that strong modern building cones aren't just technical documents. They
are the foundation of public safety. They protect our homes from fires, our businesses
from weather and severe weather in our communities from possible structure failures that can
change lives in an instant. For more than four decades we correlate with international
co council along with the board of coalition of professionals, our government leaders,
all of the city departments and a vast number of safety advocates. They have come together
to promote this mission. Working together reinforces the simple truth. Building safety
is a shared responsibility. From every inspection, every ordinance to every updated code and
every informed decision helps contribute to safe, more sustainable structures and a brighter
future. This month we honor everyone's dedication as we ask each of you to commit yourself to
help supporting safe, sustainable and affordable buildings for all of our communities. When
we invest in strong building practices, that commitment helps create a safer tomorrow for
families, businesses and future generations. Thank you for contributions and supporting
the building safety and for helping to strengthen the place we live we call Huntsville.
Thank you. You know, this proclamation is, as Alan was talking about, it makes you realize
that we have so many departments in the city and that's why this proclamation comes from
the city that work on safety, work to make sure that the structures that you live in
are safe, that the structures that you walk in are safe, that we as a community, you know
that when you leave that you can come back, you'll come back home in a safe manner. And
so this has a lot of where as's which most of them were hit by Alan talk but this says
now therefore I, Tommy Battle, mayor of the city of Huntsville, to hereby proclaim this
month, May 2026, as building safety month. Alan, thank you for the work that you all
do day to day to make each of us safe, whether we're in our home or business or just driving
around. Thank you so much.
Thank you, Council.
Thank you for your work. We now have several special recognitions and resolutions to be
offered by council members. 6A is resolution recognizing and congratulating John Blue Company
on reaching 140 years of operation in the year 2026. The chair moves for approval. Second
from Mr. Kling. All in favor please indicate. Aye. Any opposed? The motion carries. Would
John Blue, the John Blue team come forward.
Oh, I get the color code now. You all planned that, didn't you? We have Marty Gray, the CEO
of the John Blue Company and would you like to introduce your team?
Yes. Today I have with me Brian McGee, Brendan Brewer, Kim Doggett, Elizabeth VanDeevendere
and Craig Masbring with us today. The reason we are here is we are celebrating
140 years. Let me read a little bit of this resolution. Whereas the city council and the
mayor of the city of Huntsville, Alabama, wish to recognize and congratulate John Blue
Company on reaching 140 years of esteemed development, workmanship and integrity in
the year 2026, creating trusting connections with customers, employees and partners alike.
Originally founded in Norneburg, North Carolina in 1886, the company relocated to Huntsville
after a fire in North Carolina. And the company has since demonstrated a continued commitment
to meet the ever evolving needs of farmers, applicators and industries throughout the
United States. And whereas the legacy of the John Blue Company established by the company's
reputable consistency and dependability continues today as innovation is evident in their products.
Whereas throughout the year 2026, John Blue Company will recognize this milestone with
new marketing initiatives, historical highlights and continued investment in cutting edge product
solutions that will last for centuries to come. Now therefore, be it resolved that the
city council and the mayor of the city of Huntsville do hereby recognize John Blue Company
for 140 years of continued innovation, quality and reliability in their company, demonstrating
a legacy that has stood the test of time and will continue to deliver caliber products
to consumers for generations to come. We wish you a very happy additional 140 years. Thank
you for all your contributions to our community.
I would just like to thank you and the council and Mayor Battle for this recognition. It
means a lot to our company. In 140 years, we have seen a lot of things. Our company
has seen a lot of things. The Great Depression, two world wars and COVID. And so it's through
the employees that we have in the past and the present that have carried on that has
allowed this company to be so successful. The city of Huntsville has been a great partner.
We'd like to think we have played a small role in the development of the city through
the citizens that we employed and the innovations that we brought forth. And so very thankful
for this opportunity and really can't wait to continue on to be a part of this community.
Thank you for the work that you all are doing. Let me present you now with this resolution.
Thank you all so much. Thank you for being here.
Oh, you're going to get enough. Please go ahead. I'm going to scurry up here.
All right, Ms. Watkins, are you ready? We've got a bunch of them now. 6B is a resolution
commemorating the 65th anniversary of Drake State Community and Technical College. Is there
a motion to approve? So moved. Motion from Ms. Watkins, second from Mr. Little. All in
favor, please indicate. Aye. Any opposed? Motion carries. Ms. Watkins, would you like
to make that presentation? Good evening, everyone. Dr. Sims, if you want
to bring anyone up with you, you can. So I'm honored tonight to recognize J.F. Drake State
Technical and Community College and Dr. Sims, who's doing phenomenal things. You're doing
some great things, Dr. Drake. Thank you. Awesome. So whereas the City Council and Mayor of Huntsville,
Alabama recognize the significant role of J.F. Drake State Community and Technical College
has played in expanding access to higher education and advancing workforce development opportunities
for the citizens of Huntsville and North Alabama, whereas J.F. Drake State Community and Technical
College was established in 1961 in Huntsville, Alabama as Huntsville State Vocational Technical
School, opening its doors with 27 students enrolled in four technical programs. Whereas
in 1966, the institution was renamed to honor Joseph Fanning Drake, a distinguished educational
leader and longtime president of Alabama Agricultural and Mechanical University, whose leadership
and vision contributed greatly to the advancement of higher education in Alabama. Whereas in
1973, Drake State achieved technical college status and began awarding their associate and
applied technology degree, further expanding its mission to prepare students for high demand
careers. Whereas in 2013, the institution became J.F. Drake State Community and Technical
College, uniquely combined comprehensive community college academic transfer programs with advanced
technical training and workforce development programs designed to meet the evolving needs
of the community. Whereas for 65 years, Drake State has served as a critical workforce development
partner with Huntsville and North Alabama, offering associate and applied science, associates
in art, associate in science degrees, as well as short term certificates and industry recognized
credentials aligned with high demand fields such as advanced manufacturing, aerospace,
healthcare and information technology. Whereas Drake State has demonstrated leadership and
workforce innovation, including early designation as a Microsoft authorized academic training
partner, serving as an EPA HVAC certification testing site and participating in employer
driven training initiatives such as Federation of Advanced Manufacturing, also known as FAME.
Whereas the college continues to expand its capacity to train the next generation of skilled
professionals through investments in modern facilities such as the Lidos Advanced Training
Complex, which they, you cut the ribbon on last year, right? And it's a beautiful facility
to support an aerospace and advanced manufacturing education. Whereas Drake State has secured
competitive federal and workforce grants that strengthen students pathways into science,
technology and other high demand career fields, including becoming the first institution in
Alabama to receive a United States Department of Labor Strengthening Community Colleges
training grant. And as the college celebrates its 65th year during the week of April 27th,
this milestone represents six and a half decades of educational access, workforce excellence
and sustained contributions to the economy, to the economic vitality of the city of Huntsman
State, Alabama. You see, I had a lot of stuff for me to read. Dr. Samson, would you like
to say something?
Recently. She read all the whereas, so I don't have to say much. But Councilwoman Watkins,
Madam President, Mayor and City Council members, thank you. It's an honor for us to serve this
community for over 65 years. We've been providing workforce development to strengthen our community
north Alabama. And so we're really excited to continue this partnership and look forward
to the great things in the future. I have an amazing team, some of my team members here.
So we thank you for this resolution.
Oh, no problem. Now, Mayor, would you come down to take pictures with a week? We can't
leave the mayor out. Not when you got Drake in the building. Alabama, me and him up next
if you want to stay down here.
All right. Six C is a resolution honoring Alabama and Alabama and men's tennis team
in twenty twenty six. Swag regular season champions. Motion from Miss Watkins, second
from Mr. Little. All in favor, please indicate. I oppose the motion. Carry this. What? You
can be getting a workout tonight. You could be playing with the tennis team after we're
done. Yes. Yes. Can I get the Alabama and University men's tennis team to come up, please?
Mayor, you want to come down? So you all know, anytime it comes to Alabama and University,
I get super excited and I'm always happy to have the Bulldogs in the house. But I'm especially
happy tonight because they're being recognized for being the twenty twenty six Southwestern
Athletic Conference, also known as Swag Men's Tennis Champs. That's the big applause.
So, what's your name? Willis. I'm going to let the coach speak because I'm going to let
him tell a lot of these great things. Thank you, council and Mayor Battle for this wonderful
recognition. First of all, I'd like to thank our wonderful leadership, starting with our
president, Daniel K. Wims and our extraordinary athletic director and VP, Paul Bryant, our
support staff, sports medicine, academic enhancement. It's always a group effort. But most importantly,
I'd like to thank this wonderful young man for all the effort they put out throughout
the year, early mornings, late night and just laying it all on the tennis court day in,
day out with me demanding always more and more from them. You know, it's great to be
recognized by the city. And thanks for reminding us that it's not always about Alabama A&M
and it's also for the city of Huntsville that we do this great job. So thank you very much
for this recognition. Again, we want to I like to echo his sentiments and also say that
Mayor, we truly appreciate all the support. Councilwoman Watkins, again, we thank you.
You are an alum and we appreciate all that you do. We are Huntsville's only Division
One program and we know the support that you give. So we want to thank you. Say thank you.
And as always, go Bulldogs.
Thank you.
And because one championship wasn't enough, we have 6D, a resolution honoring Alabama
A&M's women's bowling team. 2026 SWAC Tournament Champions, is there a motion to approve?
Chair makes a motion. Second. Second from Ms. Watkins. All in favor, please indicate.
Opposed? Motion carries. Ms. Watkins. Can I get the women's bowling team to come up,
please? So I think it wasn't two weeks ago. We had the women's basketball team who won
the SWAC championship and the coach was the coach of the year. And then we turned around
and the tennis men's tennis wins SWAC championship and now we have the women bowling team SWAC
champions. Can I say that the Bulldogs are really showing up this year? So where is the
coach? Coach, you want to come up and say some things?
Thank you very much, Councilman. Thank you everybody for being here. What can I say?
My team here, these girls are amazing. We fought uphill the whole weekend and each time
we were on the ropes, each time we pulled it out and it was something to be a part of.
And it was an amazing run. And I'm so proud of these kids. They never gave up. These young
ladies, they never gave up. They fought to the end. And before we knew it, it was over.
We had it won and it was something that it was amazing run. So I want to thank them for
supporting us, the team. I want to thank the council, council, mayor and AD and President
Williams also for being part of this. But it's something that once in a lifetime you
get a chance to enjoy something like this. And I was blessed to be a part of something
like this. So thank you very much, Councilman. Again, we thank you. Our women, it was interesting.
They were picked not to win it. And so it was just an honor to see how hard they fought,
how great they are and how well they represented Alabama A&M. And so again, from me and from
the President, I again say thank you and congratulations and go Bulldogs.
Bulldog family, come on up.
Thank you.
Congratulations to the whole Bulldog family. Those are great wins. And then finally, because
they have to eat sometime. 6E is a resolution recognizing Gee's Country Kitchen for 30 years
of outstanding service to the Huntsville community. Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve. Motion from Mr. Kling.
Second. Second from Mr. Little. All in favor, please
indicate aye. Opposed? Motion carries.
Can I get Maurice and Gretel Russell to come up please and anybody that's here with Gee's.
Maurice and Gretel. So you cannot have lived in Huntsville, even if you've been here two
years and not heard of Gee's Country Kitchen. If you haven't, I'm just going to tell you,
you missed a treat. I remember 30 years ago when they opened this business and I came
like the second or third day because the line was out the door. And I've been a customer
ever since. But I didn't bring them here because of that. I brought them here because I don't
think people understand 30 years in the restaurant business is a significant milestone. Not only
that, our entrepreneurs drive the workforce. They create jobs within the community. And
they are in District 1 and that's one of the reasons I want to recognize them. They could
have taken up roots several times, moved somewhere else, but they stayed planted right in District
1 and for that I appreciate it. So I'm going to give you a little background. Whereas the
mayor and the mayor, you're going to come down again, aren't you? Because the mayor
eats there a lot too. Whereas the mayor of Huntsville and the city council proudly recognized
Gee's Country Kitchen, a beloved family owned and operated restaurant that has faithfully
served the community for 30 years. Whereas under the exceptional leadership of owners
Maurice and Grutter Russell, Gee's Country Kitchen has become a true cornerstone of hospitality
known throughout Huntsville for its welcoming atmosphere, quality food and steadfast commitment
to excellence. Whereas a family operated establishment, Gee's Country Kitchen represents the very
best of small business entrepreneurship, reflecting the values of hard work, perseverance and
a lasting family legacy. Whereas for three decades, Gee's Country Kitchen has provided
more than meals, often a place of fellowship, connection and community engagement. This
has become a place where residents from all walks of life gather to build strong connections,
exchange ideas, discuss business and enjoy genuine camaraderie. Whereas the Russell's
dedication to service extends well beyond this restaurant, contributing to the economic
strength and cultural richness of the city of Huntsville. Whereas the celebration of
30 years in business is a significant milestone that reflects an enduring commitment to excellence
and continued support and loyalty of the Huntsville community. Now therefore, let it be resolved
that the city council and mayor of Huntsville do hereby recognize and congratulate Gee's
Country Kitchen on its 30th anniversary and commend Maurice and Grutter Russell for their
leadership and contributions to the community. And we express sincere appreciation for their
years of service and extend best wishes for continued success in the years to come.
And I'm going to pass the mic over. A lot of people know Maurice because Maurice is out
talking and joking and making sure you're good, but this is the cook. Maurice will be
no good without the cook. But they will be no good without each other. So I'm going to
give them the mic. You said it all Michelle. Thank you. Thank you. Tell me about them.
I just want to thank each and every one of y'all. It wouldn't be no Gee's without y'all.
And I got to get back to work before I get fired. Thank y'all.
And now we'll move on to some other business. It's always fun to celebrate good things
going on. Item agenda item seven is announcements and presentations. Before we go on to the
presentation that I know everyone's waiting for, let me make one quick announcement and
that is that the city council will hold a joint meeting with the Huntsville school board
on June 1st, three to five PM in these chambers. We will be looking at development review and
demographics in the city and how future growth is going to impact the school system. And
that will be open to the public. So now we will go on to seven a an update from Huntsville
hospital regarding the Huntsville health system and crestwood transaction. We welcome the
CEO, Jeff Sam's, who is joining us tonight, as well as the crestwood board chairman of
the crest, crestwood hospital board, Michael Espy, who is no stranger to many people in
the city. We also have a number of members of the Huntsville hospital team who have joined
us tonight. We should, I should as an introduction say that Huntsville hospital operates independently
of the city of Huntsville. And we have invited Mr. Sam's to come and make a public presentation
to the council tonight. And we hope that this presentation will answer questions that residents
have asked us and provide much needed information that the hospital was not able to release
previous to the merger. So and I've also been told that Mr. Sam's will be staying after
he concludes the presentation and after citizen agenda comments out in the foyer if anybody
wants to have a private conversation has still has questions. So Mr. Sam's team, welcome.
The time is yours. Thank you. We're delighted to be with you tonight. We appreciate your
time. As President Robinson mentioned, we were unable to share these updates until the
transaction closed. And we're delighted to be here tonight to not only explain why we
believe crestwood joining our system is the right thing for the community, but also share
updates from the community about the work our health system does across North Alabama.
I'll introduce just a couple people that are here with me. First on the left here is Tracy
Doty. Tracy's both president of Huntsville hospital and executive vice president of our
Madison County operations responsible for all of our hospitals in Madison County, including
Crestwood. And I'm delighted he's here tonight. To his left, Don Webster with HMZ. No stranger
to many of this room who's been a leader in EMS for longer than he probably cares for
me to admit here with you today. Mike Gillespie was kind enough to take his personal time
to join us. He's well known in the community and I'm delighted Mike would be with us today.
Kyle Buchanan. Kyle started as the president of Crestwood Medical Center on Monday. This
is his fourth day. He was with us previously at Helen Keller. He's a native of Alabama,
a wonderful leader, a man of great integrity. And I'm delighted. I think the community
will get to know Kyle and enjoy having him here very much. I think that oh John Howe,
I cannot forget John Howe, the president of HHEMS in HMZ. John is, John's an amazing leader
in the community is lucky to have him. I appreciate all them joining me tonight. So I'm going
to talk about Crestwood. I'm going to talk about some positive things and then we're
going to we're going to welcome some questions. Okay, our board. So we treat everybody that
walks through our door. We are locally governed by the health care authority. These 11 people
up on the screen. They're volunteers. They're not shareholders. They these volunteer their
time tirelessly. This is not an easy board to be part of. Amazing community service.
Dr. Pat Sims is here tonight and I'm grateful for her leadership along with the other members
you see on this screen. In addition, in addition to these these folks, we have hospital boards
at all regional hospital boards at all of our hospitals and at HMZ. Together there's
130 volunteers helping oversee what we do. We take some criticism that we're not transparent
enough or we're not we're not volunteer led enough. I think many of these 130 people who
are involved in our governance might disagree with that. We were there volunteers are wonderful
people and we've been serving the community for 130 years. This is our footprint. 15 hospitals
on a 15 county service area. It stretches across north Alabama from from Red Bay to
to to Sheffield over to Scottsboro and Fort Payne. We're equally responsible for every
hospital on that map. We're just as responsible what we do in Red Bay and Sheffield as we
are in Huntsville and Marshall County and Scottsboro. We take that obligation very seriously.
We're very proud of the work we've done to maintain rural health care in in north Alabama.
There's a rural health care crisis in Alabama, but we like to say not in north Alabama. We're
proud of the fact that we've kept these hospitals open. With the growth of the hospital community,
there's no way we can care for everybody in Huntsville. We need strong rural hospitals.
If we're going to provide the service people deserve in Huntsville and allow neighboring
communities to have the health care they need to grow and thrive, we're really proud of
that. Our footprint creates a unique opportunity. There's nobody else who has this footprint
in Alabama and we think it's the right thing for the community and we're delighted to try
to describe that to you tonight. By the numbers, just a few quick stats of who we are. We see
363,000 patients in our ERs every year, over 100,000 admissions. We deliver over 10,000
babies, over half those babies at the Huntsville Hospital for Women and Children. That's the
busiest delivering hospital in Alabama. Huntsville has become a regional hub for health care.
Over 41% of the patients we care for in Huntsville come from outside the county into the county
for health care. That does a couple things for the local Huntsville community. One, it
creates a lot of jobs here and we'll show you that in just a minute. We've got a lot
of employment, a lot of economic growth, it's because people drive in here for health care.
It also allows us to have advanced medical care that's only possible if you have the
scale of a regional medical center. Our neonatal ICU, trauma, heart attack care, many other
programs that the community only has because of this scale. A few more of those up here
on your screen, we're very proud of our trauma program. Pediatric ER, pediatric ICU, a lot
of these things, they require both scale and they require subsidies. And if we don't have
the footprint we have, we can't offer these things to the community. Now let's talk about
Crestwood for a minute. Wonderful people at Crestwood. I want to talk for a minute about
their ownership. So Crestwood was previously owned by Community Health Systems. Community
Health Systems is a publicly traded investor owned company. They operate about 80 hospitals
across the country. They have shareholders. And reasonably until we closed the transaction
they didn't want me in the media talking about their company. That's why I couldn't talk
about this until tonight. There's wonderful people at Crestwood and I wish anybody who's
concerned about this could be in the hospital with us seeing the interactions between the
Crestwood staff and our team. We learned shortly before Thanksgiving through representatives
that Crestwood was on the market and was going to be sold. And when they approached us about
the possibility of that maintaining over local governance, we worked at that board you saw
and made a challenging decision that we felt like local governance over something as important
as healthcare was the right thing to do. We're proud to make the investment. We think it
gives us an opportunity to use capacity at Crestwood to better serve the community and
make sure every dollar is reinvested locally in our hospital. Wonderful people we've met
at Crestwood, the board, Mike, everybody. The ownership structure is different. Crestwood
is a very financially successful hospital. Most of that money was leaving our community.
Of the cash generated from the operation of Crestwood, well over 90% was leaving our community
to go to shareholders or retire their debt. That changes going forward. All of those dollars
will stay in our community and every dollar will get reinvested in the hospital. Talk
a little bit about we knew we would find some deferred maintenance needs and we want to
just describe this. So in the first 90 days we've been there, we've already committed
$4 million of capital investment in Crestwood. That's four times what they've received annually
the last four years. The money that's if we just maintain Crestwood's historical financial
success, keep that money in the community, we can fully service the debt of the acquisitions
and more than 10 times increase the capital investments into the hospital. A few examples
of what's already up there, we've approved funding for a new roof for backup water heaters
for clinical equipment. There's amazing staff at Crestwood and they deserve to have the
latest equipment to take care of their friends and neighbors. Now just if anybody wonders,
just one point of question I get, does my compensation or anybody on our team influence
by this transaction? There is nobody on our team self included that makes an extra dollar
due to the Crestwood transaction. Our compensation is completely disconnected from how we perform
at Crestwood or the acquisition itself. There's also a lot of comments about quality ratings.
A lot of this is generated by the leapfrog report where we believed it was inappropriate
that they gave us a poor score for a survey we didn't complete. Hospitals in Florida felt
the same way and filed a lawsuit and recently won that lawsuit and leapfrog was forced to
admit that we were right, that it was inappropriate to grade us that way and that grade has been
removed. Now we're preparing to complete the leapfrog survey. Our staff deserve to be recognized
for the great care they receive and we don't want the community to have that mark. So we're
preparing to complete the survey and we will do that in the future but we felt good that
that was taken away. We're proud of the quality we deliver. US News considers us the second
best hospital in Alabama to UAB and our CMS star ratings in the latest ratings that will
soon post Huntsville Hospital will become a three-star hospital Crestwood already is.
We're proud of the quality we deliver to people every day. I'll also make a brief comment
on our high reliability training program. We have spent an enormous amount of time every
day in the morning at every hospital leaders are on a phone talking about patient safety
making sure we provide great care for people. Really proud of the high reliability training
we've done. I'll talk about money. So we went from 14 hospitals to 15 hospitals.
And it generated a lot of commentary that all of a sudden we could dictate what people
pay for health care. So in order to try to put that to rest I'd like to talk for a second
about how we get paid. So if you look up there the far two right parts of the chart Medicare
and Medicaid that money comes from the federal government primarily. That's over half our
reimbursement. They pay us below cost and I have a rate taker with the federal government.
They tell me how much they're going to pay. We have to treat every single patient that
walks through the door and we do it below cost. That's Medicare and Medicaid. There's
almost 10% that's self-pay. Again we treat everyone. Caring for that self-pay percentage
generates 172 million dollars of uncompensated care. Care we do for free to make sure people
can get taken care of. Then the remaining 37% is commercial insurance. In Alabama that's
predominantly one payer. It has over 90% of the market and I assure you I cannot dictate
what they pay us for care. We are a larger regional health care system. We feel like
we've leveled the playing field a little bit but I assure you I have no ability to dictate
what people pay for health care. We do have the scale to make sure the resources are available
in our community and they all get reinvested to make sure people can get the care they
need. We do a lot of things outside the hospital walls we're really proud of. We put 14 million
dollars a year over the last few years in a community health initiative funding things
like CASA, the community free clinic and others. I'll call out one at the bottom, our athletic
trainers. We're really proud of this and I don't think it gets enough attention. Between
Huntsville and Crestwood we spend almost 4 million dollars a year putting athletic trainers
in the school system. That takes a financial burden off our school system and allows those
tax dollars to be used to make sure children get a great education. We're proud to do that
for the school system. We think it's an important investment in the community. Now I'll talk
about workforce for a minute. So we're proud of the jobs we create and being an economic
driver. We have over almost 22,000 employees right now, 63% of those in Madison County.
We updated our economic impact, our health system taken together has a 7.4 billion dollar
economic impact on the regional economy and second only to Redstone Arsenal we're the
largest employer. So let's talk about how we invest in people and where our money goes.
The pie chart on the left, 56% of our expenses goes to salaries. We're a people business.
If we don't have workforce we cannot run the hospital. So 56% of our money goes to people,
21% to supplies, pharmaceutical supplies. Uncompensated care you see now left almost
6%. Our operating margin is 2%. So we keep 2 cents on the dollar, that's our profit margin,
2% to do all this stuff for the community. You see on the right our capital investment.
We're spending 7.5% of our revenue on capital improvements and we have dramatically accelerated
that over the past few years with projects we'll show you just in a minute to make sure
this growing community has the infrastructure it needs. If there's any financial people
on the call or in the audience you take 7.5% capital investments compared to our depreciation
and amortization we're spending over 150% of our depreciation to replace our assets
and make sure we're able to grow. Again, every dollar we collect is being reinvested in our
community. We also create a lot of jobs. That's our workforce mix on the left. The line chart
is our growth including acquisitions. Have we grown? Preparing for this presentation
for the first time we went back and looked and said look if you take away the acquisitions
how many jobs have we created in the last four years? It's 2,100 jobs we've created
providing healthcare in the last four years, 70% of those in Madison County. We think we
play two roles in economic development here and in the region. To one, create jobs. Healthcare
people they pay mortgages, they pay taxes, they're here stimulating the economy and helping
recruit industry. If you go to Scottsboro and they're trying to bring people to Scottsboro
they need a hospital. And we work with Mayor McCamey and folks in Scottsboro they have
to have their regional hospital and they might not if we weren't there to help them. We've
got amazing educational partnerships some of them are here tonight. I won't go down
this, this is just some of the logos of the hundreds of institutions we work with. I don't
have to tell people in this room how blessed we are to have educational partners like this
across North Alabama. We also run a bunch of our own schools. At any given time we have
more than 200 students that are going to school in our facilities getting a free education
and a job when they graduate. Pharmacy technicians, we had an EMS graduation last week where 10
new EMTs went into the workforce. They get that free education and then they get a job
when they graduate. This happens all the time it's about a six million dollar commitment.
There's more physician training in Huntsville than I think people realize and this is something
I think we need to talk more about. First of all recruitment, we've recruited 154 physicians
to Madison County since 2022. Together with our primary partner UAB we have 137 medical
residents training at Huntsville Hospital right now. Crestwood has a residency program
with 60 additional physicians. I want the community, there's nearly 200 resident physicians
right now in Madison County getting trained. Critical for our community's growth. We're
also delighted we'll start a residency next year in Marshall County again partnering with
UAB and following that we plan to start with indicator that's well along the way. When
that's done we're looking at more than 250 residents learning and training in North Alabama
to support rural community. It's so important because over half of physicians stay where
they train and if we want to have the physician workforce we need we've got to fund these
programs. So nurses, let's talk for a minute about nurses. My mom is a nurse and she might
be watching right now so I've got to watch my P's and Q's here. The Crestwood acquisition
generated a lot of discussion that now we can control nursing labor and we don't pay
nurses enough and we never will. Let's just try to use some facts to address that head
on. Since 2022 we've hired over 4,500 nurses that accepted our offers of employment. Our
vacancy rates are below the national average at 3% and our turnover rate is consistently
below the national average. So we're hiring thousands of people, we have a vacancy rate
below the average and our turnover rates, more of them stay with us than average. And
then our compensation, we have a lot of nurses and when we go make a compensation adjustment
from nursing we're spending a lot of money and we have to be thoughtful and we have to
plan those investments. We've done it three times since 2021, $65 million, the next one
goes into effect in July and we'll spend nearly over $30 million increasing nursing compensation.
When you take it all together, how much we pay nurses, if you take the initial rate is
not the whole story. We pay more if you work nights, weekends, shift differentials, if
you'll train someone. When you take all that together, you take the amount we spend on
nursing and the amount of hours people work, our gross pay per hour across all our nurses
is over $45 an hour in July. So we're high over $4,500, our vacancy rates lower than
average in our turnover and we're paying nearly $45 an hour on average in July for our nursing
labor. Up in the upper right, 53% of Madison County nurses work in hospitals, the rest
work in clinics and in physician offices, in surgery centers, nursing homes and elsewhere.
I understand the perception, we're the largest nursing employer, there's no question, I understand
the concerns, but we don't control the market for nursing. We're trying our best to support
nursing, to support training for nursing and make sure they're compensated fairly for the
amazing work they do. A few other quick things on workforce, we've got a wonderful group,
amazing team, a childcare clinic, employee healthcare clinic, I'll go through these quickly
in the interest of time. I'm proud to partner with the city at Mill Creek to build workforce
housing in Mill Creek. I was delighted to drive down Governors and see ground moving
in Mill Creek and we will come along in a later phase and build a workforce housing
for our staff and be part of that amazing community. I want to talk quickly about a
few projects, the Madison Street Tower expansion, if you drive downtown you'll see this, we're
right on track and about a year from now we'll be caring for patients in there. This is $120
million of construction, $30 million of equipment, it's made possible by a $10 million gift,
the largest in our history, there's some really amazing people that live in Huntsville. Inside
that building will be 120 new patient rooms, state of the art ICU for cardiothoracic neurosurgery,
it will improve our ER wait times, if you're waiting in our ER, more than likely it's not
the ER, it's there are people waiting for a bed, this addresses that issue. We've opened
a lot of clinics in the last few years, I chose to highlight two, we constructed a primary
care clinic at Redstone Gateway to better serve the arsenal, in the very near future
we'll open a clinic on Alabama A&M's campus, the photo in the right is not Stock Art, I'm
going to get the name right here, that will be our first provider, that's Alabama A&M
alum Tammy Smith, who will be a physician's assistant serving her community and the broader
community in that clinic, so we look forward to a ribbon cutting very soon at Alabama A&M.
On the lower left you'll see our children's hospital, it is very busy keeping up with
the growing community, we're in the process of planning for an expansion of the children's
hospital now, we'll come out in the parking lot and get more space for babies and our children.
One comment about mental health care, we're proud of our role in that, it's a tremendous
challenge for the community, what I'd like the community to know is we're the provider
of last resort, we're the people that don't say no, we've got great partners, Wellstone
and others, but when somebody's having an acute mental health crisis they come to us
and we don't say no, no matter how full the place is, we're involved in over 90% of the
intent to file patients brought through the ER, we have a 30 bed acute unit in Huntsville
and we operate a free standing emergency, excuse me, mental health facility indicator.
Quickly emergency care, people waiting in the ER get a lot of comments, so let's talk
to some men about that.
The HHs you see on that graph are the three Huntsville emergency departments, we add Crestwood
and their free standing ER they have in Harvest.
We have recently committed to building two free standing ERs, one in North Huntsville,
one in Hampton Cove, our last regulatory approval is in a couple weeks, we expect to start construction
on those in the fall, we'll follow that by following through on the FED that Crestwood
was planning to build in Madison, at that point you get that map, that's what this growing
community needs to provide emergency care close to your home and transfers into our
hospitals when you need it.
I want to recognize HMZ, we're so proud to be part of the first responder community,
they drive over five and a half million miles across North Alabama, incredibly proud of
these folks in the middle of the night, get the answer in the call, showing up to take
care of their neighbors.
We've done a lot of work to try to get those trucks back on the road, this chart people
can look at later, what this means is wall time, so if you come in the ER we need to
get that ambulance unloaded and back in service as soon as possible, we've dedicated beds
to reduce that wait time by 75%.
In the main ER in Huntsville, the subject of a lot of comments about delays, they have
a fast track area, so if you're lower acuity you can come in and be seen, that's reduced
our left without being seen right by nearly half.
Finally a whole blood program, I'm so proud of this and the whole community, John Howe
and Don Webster and their team deserve so much credit for this, it started in HMZ, we're
expanding it to all of our services across eight counties, this makes whole blood available
on the scene, the gentleman in the picture is a hunter in Sheffield who thanked us for
investing in this to save his life, that's because of the work of these gentlemen behind
you, and we're so proud to support them and bring this across North Alabama.
I'm almost done, telemedicine, we can't do what we do across the region all from Huntsville,
we have to use the resources we have in our regional hospitals, technology opens the door
for that, the graph just shows you the growth of our telemedicine program, the most recent
addition being cardiology consultation in Marshall County, so now if you're a patient
in our Marshall hospitals, a cardiologist from Huntsville can do a consultation and
you don't have to leave Marshall and come to Huntsville to see the doctor, 90% of the
time when we do that people stay in their local community, our scale and footprint gives
us an opportunity connecting our EMR using telemedicine to make sure this is fully optimized.
Outside and I welcome your questions, here's what I want you to see in five years, I want
you to see connected hospitals where people get care close to their home when they need
it, your medical information is in one EMR, your medical images are in one database, and
you can get care close to home when you need it and have a bed in Huntsville when you need
advanced specialty care.
We have a unique opportunity to do that because of our footprint, Crestwood joining us makes
that even stronger and we're delighted that they're part of us.
I really appreciate your time, I'd welcome any questions council members may have.
Mr. Kling.
Thank you, Madam President.
Mr. Samps, thanks for coming down here, you did explain something that I didn't quite
understand at the beginning but I think being out here I think has been good, this is a
good forum, it's public and we're being televised, we're being streamed over the internet so
I think you know getting information out.
A couple of questions I've received from people and you know we just read about things to
try to you know make questions you're going to ask about.
The compensation for nursing, there seems to be some concerns that you're going to have
a bunch of Crestwood Hospital nurses coming in, what's going to happen to their salaries,
are they going to be dropped to a lower level or how's that going to be addressed?
That's a great question, no, none of the nurses actually, none of the staff at Crestwood will
see any reduction in their compensation, they all came over at comparable compensation.
Just other numbers, in July we're raising our new grad starting rate for inpatient nurses
across the health system to $29 an hour and again the gross when you take it all together
across all of our nursing in July will be about a little over $45 an hour.
We believe those rates are competitive, we compete with Birmingham, with Nashville, lots
of physicians offices for nurses and if we don't pay competitively we won't have the
staff to execute.
The Crestwood Hospital, you kept talking about Crestwood, is that going to be changed, is
that going to be known as Huntsville Hospital, is there going to be a big sign, Huntsville
Hospital and Crestwood Hospital sign comes down?
It's a great question, I'm glad you asked it because I was supposed to cover it when
I was on that slide.
Now Crestwood is staying Crestwood, a lot of people like it, it's a, there's an incredible
culture there of it's a little smaller hospital, parking's a little easier, we're going to
leave it all alone.
I have a Crestwood badge, I wear when I go over there, we respect the history, people
like Mike, Dr. Pam Hudson and others created there, we respect that, we're going to honor
it, we're going to keep that hospital the same and people like going to, if your doctor's
there, if you like the look and feel, it's going to be there for you unchanged.
Are the employees at, we'll call it Crestwood, are the employees at Crestwood, are they going
to stay there, are they in danger of losing their jobs or?
So everybody at Crestwood came over and got a fresh start.
Now just like every company, we have policies and procedures people have to follow, every
Crestwood employee came over and everybody gets treated the same going forward.
So we hope we keep them all and we're delighted to have them, it's really been an incredible
experience being in the hospital.
One thing I've learned, there are different doctors that have, what do they call it, privileges
or relationships, some are at Huntsville Hospital, some are at Crestwood, what happens to those
relationships that the doctors have that are currently involved with Crestwood Hospital?
When a physician works at a hospital, they apply for privileges at that hospital.
Huntsville and Crestwood are separate hospitals in that regard.
Some physicians have applied to have privileges at both and some work at one or the other.
None of that changed.
So the medical staff at Crestwood on March 31st and April 1st was exactly the same, it's
the same folks and they govern themselves.
So it's no change in that and doctors that work at Crestwood will stay there and some
work at both places.
Can you explain, I guess exactly what it is mentioned by privileges for a doctor at a
hospital?
When a physician wants to work at a hospital, they have to apply for membership and demonstrate
that they have the clinical competence to do what they want to do, care for patients
effectively.
Within the organization, each hospital has bylaws where physicians govern each other
along with the governing board to make sure they can do that safely and they have the
education and training to be safe and they have to get re-credentialed periodically.
So that happens in every hospital.
It's really a neat way I think physicians deliver a lot of credit for self-policing
their quality.
And one question and I hope this isn't impolite, but what protection is there going to be to
I guess keep the fees that are charged from going up?
So it's a good question.
We understand the concern people have about that, but again with most of the people we
treat everybody that walks through the door.
We have to cover it no matter what.
The federal government pays us below cost to care for people.
The only place we have to try to make that up is with commercial insurance and I'm going
to go shading with a commercial care that has 90% of the market.
They're a lot bigger than I am.
So we think we've given our community a fair shake to make sure we get our share and can
have the health care resources we need, but there is no circumstance where I can dictate
what people pay for health care.
Thank you.
Thank you Madam President.
Mr. Merida.
First and foremost, what was the purchase price?
$450 million.
Thank you.
You mentioned for me and I believe have been reinvested in Crestwood specifically and one
of those was Blood Bank.
What are the improvements that have been made to the Blood Bank?
So we've made a number.
We've approved investments.
We've only been there three weeks.
So we've approved $4 million.
Those purchases are on order to get in.
So we're actually bringing in a whole new Blood Bank system to make sure the software
and the software we use to control the disposition of blood is effective and state of the art.
So it's just that.
It's not machinery or equipment that actually process what the techs do in order to match
to make sure no one.
So they come in match.
I believe the system and I would have to call on Mr. Doty here to be more specific with
it.
I believe what it is is the technology we use to make sure when the blood you receive
is very carefully controlled so you get the right type that matches you exactly.
Every hospital will have a Blood Bank and the one that was their legacy at Crestwood
was out of date and needed to be replaced.
Mr. Doty could you elaborate on that for me?
So your question is what type of equipment we're buying?
Well no my question is if you're giving blood transfusions there's a bottom line that you
have to do.
So if Crestwood was we'll say was at that bottom line what are you doing to raise it?
What are the improvements?
Is it just IT stuff or is there actually other components?
It's IT and processing and safety.
Can you elaborate on processing and safety?
Yes sir so the machinery will help with the staff when they get ready to give the blood
to make sure it's the right type of blood.
Not that the current system didn't.
Machines don't do that people do.
Correct.
Machines will help you.
I've typed a lot of blood in my life so I don't understand what you're saying but that's
okay.
I'll talk about it more offline I don't want to take up too much time here drilling down
that deep.
Okay.
Okay thank you sir.
Sticking with blood you said HEMC can now give whole blood.
Correct HEMC has been doing that for some time.
Is there any desire to give pack cells?
I would have to defer to Mr. Howell to come answer that question.
Mr. Howell?
Yes Councilman Meredith we do carry pack fed blood cells as well and also we're carrying
fresh plasma liquid plasma in our units in the in the regional services but whole blood
is the best product according to our trauma team that they'd like to see us administer
when someone needs blood so we that's our number one desire and then we'll refer back
to pack fed blood cells if we don't have whole blood available.
Thank you sir.
You claim touched on it but why every other hospital that's been acquired has been rebranded
Huntsville Hospital.
Why is Crestwood an exception?
So in many cases when we went into some of the communities I'll use Scottsboro as an
example they want they welcome the HH logo on the hospital because they believe it inspires
trust in the community.
In the case of Crestwood there's so much pride in the brand and logo and culture at Crestwood
we felt like it was appropriate to respect that and leave that brand in place it really
wasn't more complicated than that.
Thank you.
On the EMS side of your training you you trained certain things and EMS was was one of those.
Is the EMS that you guys train for is it basic or advanced?
It's EMT ones they trace basic EMT and get them started and they have the opportunity
to continue their education on up.
On up to paramedic?
So we do EMT ones I believe.
We do EMT basic.
EMT basic is what we provide in the class and then we'll work with the community college
system to train EMT advanced in our paramedics.
Are any Huntsville firefighters been trained through your program and if not is that something
you would be hoping to?
So we have a number of Huntsville firefighters who work part time for us and a lot of them
did get their initial primary education when they were working for us but Huntsville Fire
has not they don't they have their own EMT training as part of the Fire Academy so they're
basically mimicking the same thing we're doing for the Fire Academy and then if they want
to go on to the advanced EMT and paramedic curriculum Huntsville Fire will also support
them to go into the community colleges I believe.
Okay thank you.
What's the retention on all of the different schools that you conduct?
How long do they have to work for Huntsville Hospital System in order not to have to pay
it back?
It varies by job and I can't quote them all.
I'm happy to get that and follow up with you.
Generally speaking I'll say for nursing our expectation is we're asking for about a year
of service if we make a $5,000 for each $5,000 investment.
That's a generality just as a general frame of reference they vary by description.
That's fine.
How does Workman Comp work within the system?
The patients we care for for workers compensation?
So that's we work with many of the physicians offices we have a workers compensation management
company and we the physicians offices in town play a huge role in that in helping direct
the care of those patients so they get cared for just like anyone else following all the
regulations for workers compensation.
I know I should know this one but does the City of Huntsville send its folks to your
system for treatment?
As far as I know but I again yes I'm getting a yes.
Thank you.
You had talked about not being able to set the prices Blue Cross Blue Shield and others
do that.
As you have acquired more hospitals aren't you able to leverage that to get better rates?
So we try to make sure our hospitals get paid fairly.
We benchmark other hospitals in the state and I'm trying to make sure a hospital in
our system has a level playing field with other hospitals a similar size.
So we do work together to make sure we get paid fairly.
We also take various issues not trying to take advantage in any way of our position
on rate reimbursement.
So it does benefit the community but in no way do I dictate what those prices are.
We negotiate with Blue Cross along with other payers for what those rates might be.
For the whole system or for individual hospitals within the system?
The whole system.
Excellent.
And finally you had mentioned delivery services and how many are delivered here.
Are there delivery services in all of the hospitals?
We have delivery services in all of our hospitals.
We do not deliver babies in Red Bay, small hospital in Red Bay Alabama.
Trying to look at my team.
I think we deliver babies in all of our other hospitals.
We do not in Parkway.
In Morgan County we deliver babies at Decatur but not at Parkway.
But except for Decatur West which is behavioral health, Parkway and Red Bay we have delivery
services in each community.
Thank you.
I'm not surprised about Red Bay.
I don't suspect they have a whole lot of need for it.
Thank you very much.
Yes sir.
Thank you.
Thank you Madam President.
Thank you Mr. Meredith.
Mr. Little.
Thanks Madam President.
Thanks for the great presentation Mr. Sams.
Thank you.
I think a little personal privilege.
My family has had everything from cut fingers because they didn't know how to cut an onion
to broken bones, heart valve replacement, trauma patients, babies delivered all at Huntsville
Hospital.
And we've never once thought about going anywhere else.
And I just obviously wish you all the continued success with this growth especially from a
regional aspect which is the one question I have about ambulance service.
It's actually something Tracy and I talked about a while back.
This was before the acquisition of HMSE.
But if somebody was being transported say from Scottsboro to Huntsville and then that
ambulance is headed back empty and they pass a rec because they couldn't help.
Something like that because they weren't either licensed or cleared to work.
But now with the broader scope of the ambulance service that care and response time I would
assume is improving.
Yeah we have an incredible opportunity to share resources across the EMS services.
It's still connected to each community through the 911 centers.
An example of how that might help keep an ambulance on the road.
So if an ambulance is going back to Marshall South which is in Boaz and we have a patient
who needs to go to Boaz we can try to make sure we send that patient back on that ambulance
that brought a patient in instead of taking a HMSE unit and driving to Boaz and back.
There's incredible efficiencies we can generate.
We're just scratching the surface of that.
So many more opportunities and I'm lucky to have people like John and Don to help lead
that effort.
That's great.
And then this just popped in my head.
Alabama isn't the best state for private hospitals to be successful.
Is that kind of the case or could be the case?
Alabama is one of the most difficult hospitals to operate a hospital in.
We have some of the lowest reimbursements in the state.
Our Medicare rates are low.
We're a non-expansion state for Medicaid and we have a dominant insurance market dominated
by one payer.
We're proud of the care we deliver in that context.
We think we deliver affordable health care for the business community that lets businesses
compete and provide affordable insurance premiums while delivering an outstanding and complex
care.
So we're proud of it.
It's not easy and I appreciate the team we have to make it happen.
Great.
That's it.
Thank you, Madam President.
Mrs. Watkins.
Good evening.
So I must say this is a little late in the game for us to be talking about this because
constituents had questions from the beginning.
We received numerous emails, numerous phone calls, not just myself but other council members
and all we could tell them, what I could tell them was I may request several times and all
I was told was there's acquisitions in place so we can't discuss it publicly.
But as an elected official and as a representative for my district, operating transparency at
all times, even when it's difficult, even when it's controversial, you have to stand
in your truth.
And I'm disappointed because Huntsville Hospital did not offer that to the citizens.
And they wanted those questions answered and they just wanted simple questions answered.
You didn't have to go into the weeds but you didn't come and show up for that.
And for that I'm disappointed.
Even more so disappointed that on several occasions, the last email I sent you I said
I need a timeline and there was no timeline shared.
You just told me that sometime in April you'll come to the council.
That's just so unacceptable to me.
And I have to stand and tell you this in front of the citizens because you having a meeting
with us last week and asking us what questions we have, that's all well and fine but the
citizens have questions.
When I operate in a back room and I don't come and tell my citizens or the people that
I represent, that puts me in a bad light and I don't like that.
So moving forward, I remember you and I never really started on a good foot anyway because
and you know I'm just being transparent because I asked for someone that lived a resident
of my district to be on the board and your response was there's a certain skill set.
And Ms. Robinson even repeated that on the microphone here.
And so I communicated with you several times because I was trying to work with you.
I was trying to build a relationship.
I even went to the mayor and said hey, can I offer four or five names from my district
that are more than qualified that have the skill set, that have the education, that have
the background?
Because see when you talk about skill sets in my district, I don't really know what you're
talking about because my district has GEDs and PhDs.
My district has zero income to multimillionaires.
My district has business owners.
My district is hardworking individuals who deserve respect and I feel they've been disrespected.
So with this new merger, I would like to know is district one going to be considered to
have someone, a resident of district one, not someone that works in district one, but
a resident of district one on the board?
I'll try my best to respond to all of that.
First of all, I want to have a great relationship with you and all members of the council.
You got one with them.
I hope I...
You just don't have one with me, right?
Well, I would like to have a great relationship with you.
I would too.
We're proud of the work we do in North Huntsville.
The freestanding ER will be the largest healthcare investment made in the history of North Huntsville
and we're proud to do that.
We're proud partners of Alabama A&M.
We have a lot of staff to work there and we want it to work extremely well.
Regarding the transparency, we signed non-disclosure agreements.
CHS is a publicly traded company.
I was not allowed to answer questions.
I would have been violating a contract I signed.
All the media information we shared and we went to great lengths had to be vetted and
approved by them before I could put it out there.
It's what I had.
I didn't like it.
As soon as the transaction closed, we went on TV the next day to try to address questions
and I'm here tonight to address any question you all have and I'll be in the lobby when
I'm done if anybody in the audience wants to talk.
We want to be transparent.
I'm sorry I couldn't answer the question sooner.
As far as the board, I absolutely agree with you.
There are people in District 1 who are qualified to serve on our board.
We have 11 members on our board.
I have tremendous respect for them.
They're responsible for a 10-county region across North Alabama.
When we have a vacancy, I would welcome the opportunity to dialogue with you about, I'm
certain there are qualified people in District 1 who would be great board members and we'd
be happy to build a relationship with you going forward.
I appreciate that.
And I'm going to hold you to your word because every council member sitting on this desk
has someone or more than one person in their district representing them.
And I know before anyone goes into the weeds and say it's not district specific, but there's
a perception.
If every district is represented except District 1, and I'm always going to go hard for my
district.
If you don't know, you need to just research a little bit about me.
I'm going to go hard for District 1 every day of the week.
I'm not going to let the gas up on nobody and that includes you.
I respect what you do for District 1 and your leadership of it.
I get the same, the folks in Decatur would like to have a member of our board where we
have a hospital there.
But it's called Huntsville.
It's called Huntsville.
We serve 1.5 million people across all these counties.
It's my responsibility to take care of my wall.
Well, maybe you should take some of them out of the district that have multiple people
in the district.
Then you'll be able to expand it out and give it to other districts that's not represented.
Again, I welcome the chance to build a relationship with you.
We welcome your input about our board and I am confident there are qualified members
in your district.
I'm going to take it to your word on that because what I really feel like, I don't feel
like I know it was what happened.
You were bucking me when I wanted someone from District 1.
You were going to prove to me that you weren't going to get one, nobody on District 1.
It is a fact and I'm just saying that's what happened.
But I'm just telling you going forward, I want someone on that board that lives in District
1.
Ms. Robinson, I'm having a dialogue with him.
I'm not being rude.
But you are and it's disrespectful.
It's not disrespectful.
He's Mr. Sam's is here.
It's disrespectful to you.
No, you're being disrespectful by cutting me off when I'm up here having a conversation.
Now, you might not agree with what I say and you might not like it, but I'm not being disrespectful.
Mr. Sam's is here as an invitation as our guest to give us information.
And as a council member, I have a question and if I have a question, I'll say, you don't
get to determine what's disrespectful because you're disrespectful.
When you said District 1 had needed a certain skill set, was that not disrespectful?
Were you being disrespectful when you said that it needed a certain skill set?
Were you being disrespectful?
The reason we're here tonight is to talk about the press would have to say so.
Well, I'm just asking you want to talk about disrespect.
Let's talk about disrespect.
Madam President, I'd like to ask for a five-minute recess.
I think that's a wonderful idea.
We will take a five-minute recess.
We will reconvene at 6.55.
One minute is a few minutes.
One minute is seven minutes.
Two minutes.
We will be asking for a five-minute recess.
Madam President, if it is the reason for that, then I think you should talk about ağerek,
whatever, no matter what it is.
you
we will reconvene in 30 seconds
me
We will reconvene the meeting.
Councilmembers Kling, Little, Watkins and Robinson are present.
And a quorum is established again to continue the meeting.
We were at the point of asking questions to Mr. Sams regarding the Crestwood acquisition.
Are there any other questions anyone has?
I do have one.
I was wondering if I could finish.
I wasn't done.
Do you have a question?
I asked if you had a question regarding the Crestwood merch.
Well, you snapped off real quick.
So I was asking questions before you adjourned.
Please ask your question.
Thank you.
Please don't interrupt me.
As the health care authority for the City of Huntsville is now operating facilities
in multiple States, Alabama and Lincoln Health in Tennessee, are you now an interstate entity
and are you subject to our oversight, State oversight or Federal oversight?
I'm not an attorney and I'm not sure I'm the best person to answer that question.
We're incorporated as a health care authority in Alabama and our governance comes through
the Health Care Authorities Act of Alabama through the 11 member board I shared.
Anything more technical than that, I would have to get a legal opinion.
I don't want to say something misleading up here tonight.
Well, when you get an opportunity, I would like the question answered and you can email
it to me.
I'll have to get the transcript.
Make sure I get this.
I'll email you the question.
Very good.
Thank you.
I'm done because I might get interrupted again.
Let me ask one more question about governance.
How is the, Crestwood currently has a governing board.
How will that function as a result of the acquisition?
Each of our hospitals, our primary 11 member system board or authority board that we showed
you the pictures of is our fiduciary board that oversees the financial matters of the
whole health system.
At each of our hospitals and with EMS, we have a hospital board or an EMS board that
oversees quality medical staff credentialing.
That will be the case at Crestwood and we're excited to have Mike back on that board along
with most of the other members that have been there in the past.
Thank you again, Mr. Sams for your presentation.
Thank you to the entire Huntsville hospital team.
We appreciate the information that has been shared tonight, not just about the Crestwood
acquisition but about the function of the entire system and how it benefits all of North
Alabama.
We appreciate your time and your presence here and thank you for offering to stick around
and answer any questions anybody has out in the lobby.
We appreciate the opportunity.
I want to thank all our hardworking staff, myself and some of our team will be out in
the lobby for 20 minutes or so if anybody in the audience has a question for us.
Good night.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
We'll go on then with the business of the city to public hearings.
We have no matters with outside local representation.
We will go on to public hearings to be held.
9A is a public hearing authorizing community development to assess the cost for cleanup
and removal of adjunct public nuisance located at 2407 Oakwood Avenue, Northwest Huntsville,
Alabama and consideration of a resolution pertaining to the same.
Mr. Irwin.
Yes, Mayor Battle, Council Member Scott Irwin, Community Development Department.
As the President identified, this is a public hearing authorizing community development
to assess the cost of cleanup for removal of adjunct public nuisance at 2407 Oakwood
Avenue.
The total amount of the lien assessment for the adjunct removal was $1,712.13.
Thank you, Mr. Irwin.
The public hearing is now open on the matter of 9A.
Is there anyone here who wishes to comment on this item?
Is there anyone wishing to comment?
Seeing none, the public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve the resolution?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little.
Second.
Second from Mr. Kling.
Is there any discussion or questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
The motion carries.
9B is a public hearing authorizing the demolition of an unsafe building constituting a public
nuisance located at 1302 Boxwood Drive, Northwest Huntsville, Alabama and consideration of a
resolution pertaining to the same.
Mr. Irwin.
Yes, Council Members.
This item, 9B, is the demolition and approval of a public nuisance for 1302 Boxwood.
There are four items related to one parcel with separate addresses, so you will deal
with these individually.
So again, 1302 is similar to 4, 6 and 8, but this property has had multiple owners over
the last 8 years.
Owners have come in with the intent to renovate and modernize the project, finding it is not
economically feasible to continue with that kind of a plan.
The property continues to be a nuisance, a hazard and a blight to the neighborhood.
We had an independent contractor evaluate all four buildings, but particularly 1302
was deemed a 100 percent loss, so it wasn't economically viable for any additional rehabilitation.
In addition, this property has been used as a homeless encampment.
The homeless services team has been on site to share information about available resources
and services, including shelter options, transportation assistance, behavioral health resources and
housing.
And our goal with that respect is to ensure that every individual is aware of the help
available to them and connecting with the services that best meet their needs.
This afternoon, our attorney representing the owners contacted me.
Their intent is to complete this demolition themselves.
Upon your approval of these public actions tonight, upon your approval, I have made an
agreement with the owner of record that we would give them roughly 60 days to complete
the demolition themselves.
But upon your approval, if they have not completed the demolition by June 30th, then your effect
of authorizing the demolition would go into effect.
Thank you, Mr. Irwin.
The public hearing is-
One other thing.
Yes.
That additional time will allow additional resources to go into the unhoused community
as we work with them to make sure everyone has some path out of that into a more permanent
solution.
Thank you, Mr. Irwin.
The public hearing is now open.
Good evening.
My name is Rylan Lusk.
I'm the attorney that Mr. Irwin referenced.
Could you just give us your city of residence for the record?
Well, so I live in the county.
Okay.
I practice here nonstop.
Thank you.
Yes, ma'am, on Church Street.
I was retained about six hours ago by the property owners, but I had a very constructive
conversation with Mr. Irwin and Mr. Riley as well.
I certainly appreciate the city's willingness to give my folks a little bit more time to
get their own contractor in for this demolition.
They have put out, my understanding is, three bids, and all that remains to be done is to
hire someone to come in and start work.
So I believe the 60 days will be more than enough time for the property owners to get
in and get busy.
Thank you, sir.
Is there anyone else who wishes to comment on this item?
Seeing none, the public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Meredith, second from Mr. Little.
Do you have questions for Mr. Irwin?
I have a question.
Yes, sir.
I would like the attorney, if he could contact our office, I would like to have a further,
more in-depth discussion with you.
Thank you, sir.
And Mr. Irwin, again, if you could just clarify this.
So we are voting on this item here, but the successive other three items are also going
to be part of this consideration here.
Yeah, actually.
Item C will be 1302, item C will be 1304, then 1608.
At the moment, yes, you are voting on demolition and approval of a public nuisance for 1302
Boxwood Drive.
Very good.
Any other comments, questions?
Question or comment?
Yes, Mr. Clerk.
Just as a question first.
Okay.
We got an attorney.
We are hearing 60 days.
That is great.
If nothing happens in 60 days, does Mr. Irwin have the authority to lower the boom immediately?
Is that what we are doing?
Yes, that is what we are doing.
Mr. Irwin, would you like to?
So, as I understand, once you approve this tonight, if you authorize the public nuisance
and the demolition, you are giving me the discretion to work with the owner in a timely
manner to make sure that it does indeed get completed in that timely manner.
Okay.
I just want to make sure we had everything clarified for the record, and I am assuming
that what we are saying for this motion will carry over for the other motions also.
Thank you, Madam President.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
No.
All in favor, please.
9C is a public hearing on authorizing demolition of an unsafe building constituting a public
nuisance located at 1304 Boxer Drive, Northwest, Huntsville, Alabama, consideration of a resolution
pertaining to the same.
Mr. Irwin?
Yes, Councilmembers, 1304 video is before you on the screen.
Again, same conditions apply for 1304.
We are seeking your authorization to declare a public nuisance and abate this nuisance.
The public hearing is now open.
Is there anyone who wishes to comment?
Seeing none.
The public hearing is closed.
Motion to approve.
Second.
Motion from Mr. Meredith, second from Mr. Kling.
Any comments?
I did have a question.
What is the percent loss on this one?
Or are they all?
They are all 100 percent.
Thank you, sir.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
9D. 9D is a public hearing on authorizing the demolition of an unsafe building constituting
a public nuisance located at 1306 Boxer Drive, Northwest, Huntsville, Alabama, consideration
of a resolution pertaining to the same.
Again, Mayor, Councilmembers, the 1306 Boxwood video is before you on the screen.
Again, we are seeking authorization for declaring a public nuisance and authorization to demolition.
Thank you.
Public hearing is now open.
Is there anyone who wishes to comment?
Seeing none.
The public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Meredith, second from Mr. Little.
Any questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
9E is a public hearing on authorizing the demolition of an unsafe building constituting a public
nuisance located at 1308 Boxwood Drive, Northwest, Huntsville, Alabama, consideration of a resolution
pertaining to the same.
Yes, Councilmembers, 1308 conditions are on the video for your review.
We are asking you to authorize the public, the condition of a public nuisance exists
and authorize the demolition.
Public hearing is now open.
Is there anyone wishing to comment?
Seeing none.
The public hearing is closed.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Meredith, second from Mr. Kling.
Any questions or comments?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you, Councilmembers.
Thank you, Mr. Irwin.
9F is a public hearing on the zoning of 2.80 acres of land lying on the south side of Capshaw
Road, east of Balch Road to Neighborhood Business C1 District and the consideration of an ordinance
pertaining to the same.
Good evening, Councilmembers.
Mayor Battle, Thomas Nunez, manager of planning and zoning services.
This item was recently annexed into the City of Huntsville.
It is located south side of Capshaw Road and east of Balch Road.
A petition seeking to zone the property Neighborhood Business C1 District, which is consistent
with adjacent properties as well.
It is overall 2.8 acres and seeking to be re-zoned for a commercial use.
Thank you, Mr. Nunez.
The public hearing on this item is now open.
Is there anyone wishing to comment?
Seeing none, the public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve the ordinance?
Motion to approve.
Second.
Motion from Mr. Merritt, second from Mr. Little.
Any comments or questions?
Question.
Mr. Merritt.
Do we know what commercial use is going to go in there yet or?
An office component.
Thank you, sir.
You're very welcome.
Any other comments?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
9G is a public hearing on the rezoning of 59.21 acres of land lying on the west of North
Memorial Parkway south of Bob Wade Lane from Residence 1 and Residence 2B, Districts to
Highway Business C4 District and consideration of an ordinance pertaining to this name.
Council Member, this request is a petition to re-zone from Residence 1 District and Residence
2B, District to Highway Business C4 District.
It is overall 59.21 acres.
This property is just south of the North Huntsville Village development and is the future site
of Huntsville Hospital north side location.
Thank you, Mr. Nunez.
The public hearing on this item is now open.
Is there anyone here wishing to comment?
Seeing none, the public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Second.
Motion from Mr. Merritt.
Second from Mr. Little.
Any comments or questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
9H is a public hearing on, thank you, Mr. Nunez.
9H is a public hearing on a vacation of right of way at 2204 1st Street.
Mr. Nunez.
Absolutely.
This item is located just north of 9th Avenue and west of 1st Street.
A petition is seeking to vacate an alleyway that was established via Platte Book 1, page
166 in November of 1936.
Bear with me as I turn the zoning districts off and you get a better view of what is actually
transpiring on the property.
There's an existing church there and this church has, there's not a built actual infrastructure.
The church has been occupying this area.
They are looking to advance and do some improvements on this property and seeking to vacate the
property for future expansion of the church.
Thank you.
Is there anyone here who wishes to comment on this item?
Anyone wishing to comment?
The public hearing is now closed.
There will be no motion or action taken on this item until we get to 18C and D.
That's correct.
Thank you, council members.
Thank you.
So we will move on to public hearings to be set.
10A is a resolution to set a public hearing on the proposed creation of a tax increment
financing district tentatively named TIFF 9 pursuant to Alabama Code section 11-99-1
at sequent?
At any rate.
Is there a motion to set the hearing for May 14, 2026?
So moved.
Second.
Motion from Mr. Kling.
Second from Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries and the hearing is set.
10B is a resolution to declare a public nuisance located at 4109 Burroughs Avenue, Southwest
Huntsville, Alabama to set a date for when objections will be heard.
Is there a motion to set the hearing for the May 14, 2026 regular council?
Move to set the hearing.
Motion for Mr. Kling.
Second.
Second from Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
The hearing is set for May 14.
10C has been deleted at the request of the sponsor.
This brings us to 11, agenda related public comments.
This portion of the meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address the council on
matters relating to the specific content of items on the meeting agenda.
These individuals have signed up before the meeting.
And when called, please approach the microphone, state your name, home address, and city of
residence.
The speaker may address the council for three minutes.
Speakers shall refrain from entering into a dialogue with council members or city staff
and from making comments regarding the good name and character of any individual.
The first person to have signed up is Nick Freevold.
Freevold.
Thank you.
Nick Freevold.
The subject is item 20A, the rail study.
Mr. Freevold, please come forward.
Hi.
I'm Nick Freevold, 3903 Cypress Avenue, Southwest Huntsville.
I support the passenger rail study for Huntsville to continue to grow and be the best city in
Alabama.
We need high speed and high quality passenger rail.
High speed rail is something all the best cities around the world have and it's something
that Huntsville deserves.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
The next person to comment is Tony Gaskin.
The subject is Huntsville Hospital.
Hello.
My address is correct on the sheet.
My name is Tierney Gaskin and I live in Huntsville, Alabama.
Very good.
Perfect.
So I would first like to say thank you to Michelle Watkins for bringing up the points
we all were thinking, but none of you were asking except for Councilwoman Watkins.
But with the acquisition of Crestwood Medical Center, Huntsville Hospital has successfully
built itself a monopoly on the healthcare services in northern Alabama.
They now have 13 hospitals across 10 counties.
I'm not going to bore you with all of the details, but they do own all of the hospitals
in seven counties, including the one above us in Tennessee.
You can't even escape the Huntsville Hospital system by leaving the state.
The next closest hospital that you can go to that isn't Huntsville Hospital owned is
55 miles away in Coleman.
Who's going to Coleman?
Respectfully.
Okay.
Huntsville Hospital is blatantly in violation of several antitrust laws.
Let me be quite clear.
This is a crime.
It is against the FEC.
It is against the Clayton Act.
And to summarize, the Clayton Act, an illegal merger occurs when two companies join together
in a way that substantially lessen competition or tend to create a monopoly in a relevant
market.
This reduction in competition can harm consumers by potentially leading to higher prices or
fewer choices for products or services.
It can also harm workers by potentially leading to lower wages or fewer choices for employment.
And this is just one example of the laws broken by Huntsville Hospital and their very large
system.
The monopoly increases risk for patients and staff alike, with staff too afraid to speak
up when management demands unsafe ratios and when staff can't take off medically recommended
time to recover from their own health issues due to restrictive time off policies, it is
an increase of accidents in patient care.
How can we expect them to be able to take care of us if they can't take care of themselves?
The maternity floor cannot take the recommended time off at Huntsville Hospital because they
have no paid parental leave, maternity or paternity at all.
It's all unpaid.
We cannot reasonably expect people to be able to take the time off in this economy without
paid leave.
And that's one of the several ways they underpay their employees, on top of the fact that new
nurses make more money than nurses that they are studying after.
When the pay bump goes up, the nurses that actually work there currently do not receive
that pay bump in their base pay.
That's not how that works.
So the new nurses who come in get paid more than the old nurses, so then the old nurses
quit, leave the entire region of this state, and then all we have is new nurses.
Hey, I'd rather have a nurse who's been in the same place for 15 years working than a
nurse that's been working for two years, who is just here to collect years of experience
so that they can leave too.
Thank you for your comments.
Thank you.
The next person to comment will be Jerry Cox.
Subject is 20 AB.
Is Mr. Cox here?
Don't see him.
And then the last person to sign up is Alan, it looks like Alan Marshall, and it says the
agenda item is visitor.
I think that may be a mistake.
Mr. Marshall?
Here.
Then we will move on.
To more comments, this comment, first comments will be from the mayor and then council member
comments.
Thank you, Madam President, to keep it brief.
Just remember, Panoply is this weekend.
I think it's going to be a great weekend.
There might be a little bit of rain, but it's Panoply.
We're used to it.
We'll get through that.
Also, the Council of PTAs is meeting Sunday night and has a meeting, and it's a great
time to say thank you to our teachers for a great year and for all that they've done.
And also thank you to our school administration for the work that they've done to make sure
that our young people are educated and educated well.
Thank you, Madam President.
Thank you, Mayor Battle.
There's no way to cure a statewide, better way to cure a statewide drought than have
Panoply.
It's going to rain right away.
Okay.
We will now move to council member comments and we will start with Ms. Watkins.
Good evening.
On May 8th, Vulcan will have a barbecue competition in District 1.
It's a free community event.
It will be at 4210 Springfield Road across from Stoner Field.
They are inviting the community to come out.
It's from 2 to 5 o'clock, again, on May 8th.
They're going to have activities for the kids.
They're going to have barbecue competition, and they're even going to do tours of the
facility.
So I would definitely encourage you, if you have time, to please go out.
I went on a tour and I got to learn a lot about the facility.
My last comment, I want to say, Madam President, I would like the record to reflect that conduct
which silences or diminishes an individual, even when presented as procedural or censorship,
has the principles of respectful discourse in this chamber.
I have made multiple requests with you to please stop interrupting me when I'm talking
and you continue to do it every time.
Councilwoman Robinson, I'm formally re-interrting that request and expect it to be honored moving
forward.
I do not interrupt you and anyone else when y'all are talking.
I expect that same respect whether you agree with what I say or not.
You're trying to censor me.
And I'm not going to allow it to happen.
Thank you, Ms. Watkins.
We'll go on to Mr. Kling.
Thank you, Madam President.
Well, this past weekend, early part of the week, myself, Councilmembers Robinson and
Little, Mayor Battle, came back from the Chamber of Commerce, Washington, D.C. trip.
And I'm sure others will be talking about it in depth.
What I think is really a good thing to point out about this thing is the fact that we had
over 200 elected officials, civic leaders, business leaders from Huntsville, City of
Madison, Madison County, and several other North Alabama communities all come together
to go up to Washington, D.C.
And after looking at what goes on on the network news with Washington, D.C., and perhaps even
a little bit down in Montgomery, all the infighting that takes place, all the squabbling, one
party's in favor of something, the other party automatically is going to be against it, all
the lines that get drawn in the sand, so to speak.
Here was a chance where we saw numerous people representing their best ideas, paying – many
of them paying for the trip out of their own pocket, going up to lobby, to advocate, to
state our case as a complete team of 200-plus people all working together.
And I think that was very refreshing.
It was something I was really happy to see.
Additionally, I, on a more somber note, want to point out that tomorrow night, Friday night,
at the Davidson Center at 5 o'clock, the community is going to be saying goodbye to
Deborah Barnhart, who has been the former director of the Space and Rocket Center.
We certainly miss her passing.
She was a great person with what she had done to help perpetuate the interest of space exploration
in our community, and she will be greatly missed.
So again, that is going to be going on for the community, 5 o'clock, Friday night, at
the Davidson Center at the Space and Rocket Center.
That's all I have.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Kling.
Mr. Little.
Thank you, Madam President.
Next Thursday at 5.30, we'll be holding a town hall meeting out at the residence at
Well Point.
That's in Hampton Cove, along with Dr. Sutton and Holly McCarty from the school board and
the superintendent and some other representatives from the city to talk about what all is happening
in the Cove.
I look forward to that, and I hope it doesn't rain on Panoply.
That's all I got.
Thank you, Mr. Little.
Mr. Meredith.
Thank you, Madam President.
There is a road issue that has been brought to my attention by several people on Burgring
Road, kind of in the vicinity of the new fire station.
I want folks to know that the preliminary work on fixing that has already begun, and
in about a week, weather permitting, the new asphalt will be laid, and hopefully that will
be taken care of for a very, very long time.
Earlier this week, I was notified of some serious road issues on Waltrana Highway.
The particular issue are a number of very large potholes on a stretch of road.
We sent our public works department out there, and they have already filled in those potholes,
but the issue is all of them were not filled in.
But the reason all of them were not filled in is because that portion of the road is
one of those multi-jurisdictional roads in District 5.
So we are notifying the other jurisdiction of these potholes, but that is, if you're
traveling that stretch of road, that is why those other potholes are theirs, because they're
not ours to fix.
There are some serious issues going on with road blockages out in the Providence, Village
of Providence neighborhood.
At this service, notice that commercial loading and unloading of supplies for businesses located
within Providence cannot block the public roadways.
The city's zoning department has been notified, will be notifying all the businesses in the
area that despite what the developer has told them, there is to be no parking in the road
for pickups, deliveries, and or any other purpose.
More importantly, parking enforcement has been made aware of the flagrant violations
and will be spending far more time in the village in order to issue citations to delivery
vehicles who continue to block an already challengingly narrow streets of this community.
I was lucky enough to be able to attend a two-day innovation showcase hosted by Columbia
High Schools featuring their students.
This two-day showcase was a huge success and reinforces that Huntsville City Schools is
indeed producing not only cognitive thinking graduates, but future leaders for our city.
I want to thank all the students who voluntarily participated in the showcase, as well as the
faculty and staff who made it all possible.
I want to give a big thank you to the folks over at Abacos Systems for inviting me to
participate in their ribbon cutting for their new state-of-the-art facility in District
5 yesterday.
Not only was it a first-class event, but now that we are participants in an active war,
their contributions will help to ensure our nation's warfighters make it home alive, whether
their theater of operations are air, land, or sea.
I also want to thank the Committee of 100 for taking an interest in the potential for
shared services among the multiple jurisdictions that comprise District 5 and inviting me to
share my thoughts on how those services should move forward.
And finally, I want to thank the Alabama School of Cyber Technology and Engineering for the
invitation to their recent ribbon cutting and groundbreaking.
It has truly been a pleasure to support this venture at every turn, and I wish and watch
the tremendous growth of this institution.
Thank you, Madam President.
And thank you, Mr. Meredith.
Yesterday was Administrative Professionals Day, where we had the opportunity to thank
our council staff in particular, Sarah Powell, Samantha Scannell, Lily Wynborn.
Many of you who have called the council office, who have had the opportunity to visit, know
that they are incredible professionals, and I just want to publicly thank them for the
work they do for us and for our citizens every day.
We also had the opportunity today to attend the longevity luncheon for our employees who
have been with the city for 25 years, 30 years, 35 years, 40 years.
And in one case, the case of David DeLisser, who works in our Parks and Recreations Department,
he's been with us for 44 years, doing a wonderful job.
And anybody who has participated in any city events has seen David out there directing
a crew to set up and take down for those events.
So we thank all of our employees because they make the rest of us look really good.
As Mr. Kling mentioned, Mr. Little and Mr. Kling and I had the opportunity to go to the
on the Chamber trip.
I haven't been since 2019.
I had forgotten really how valuable those trips are.
We heard from leaders in DC, including Speaker of the House Mike Johnson and the Majority
Leader Steve Scalise.
And everyone talked about how there is something special happening in North Alabama.
And we see it every day here, but I'm gratified to see that others see it as well, particularly
at that leadership level.
And that they recognize that there are really good things going on here, whether we're talking
about Artemis, our part in the Artemis launch, Space Command, the move at the FBI, the work
that's being done on various DOD projects.
We all were recognized for that work and felt a very strong commitment, again, from leadership
at very high levels for the work that's going on here.
So we can all be very proud of that.
But I think one of the things that I found most interesting was when Senator Katie Britt
brought along one of her fellow senators, Senators Chris Coons, who is from Delaware
and a Democrat.
And they talked about how they work together and how they have been able to set aside their
differences to accomplish the work that needs to be done.
And Senator Britt said that this is not how work is normally done on the Hill, but they
have been able to set aside their differences, work together, and as a result, get more done.
And I think that's a good model for all of us.
And then finally, I will be hosting a town hall on May 7th at the Sandra Moon Complex
at 6 o'clock.
Our focus is going to be on the development review.
We have our city demographer, James Vandiver, who is going to be presenting that.
And as he always does, he comes every year, he will drill it down to District 3 and what
we're seeing in District 3 and what we can look at for growth and what impact that is
going to be having there.
So I hope you can join us.
That concludes comments.
We will excuse Mayor Battle.
He had another commitment tonight and has left us for that, but we continue to have
all the council members here and we'll go on with business.
To 14A, the Finance Committee Report.
14A is a resolution authorizing expenditures for payment.
I move for the authorization and approval of expenditures in the amount of $33,866,708.71.
Second.
The motion was made by Mr. Meredith, second for Mr. Kling.
Any questions for Mr. Meredith?
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
The motion carries.
14B is an ordinance approving appropriations, goods or services for District 1 council improvement
funds.
The chair will make a motion to approve.
Is there a second?
Second.
Second for Mr. Kling.
Ms. Watkins, would you like to share with us what you're doing with those funds?
I have 11 schools in my district and I'm donating $1,000 per school.
$500 to principal books, $500 to PTA.
Anyone that knows me knows I am a former educator.
Schools mean a lot to me and PTAs need some funds so they can get parents involved.
Anytime you have parental involvement in schools, schools excel, kids learn, kids want to learn,
they want to be involved because they want to be pleasing to the adults.
So I'm donating this money because I feel this is a much needed cause in my district
and just want to support the schools.
Any questions or comments?
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
The motion carries.
14C is an ordinance approving appropriations, goods or services for District 3 council improvement
funds.
The chair moves for approval.
Second.
Second for Mr. Little.
I am trying to make it equal.
I know, I appreciate that.
Maybe somebody's watching.
So this is a $15,000 allocation that is being made to support Ditto Landings Independence
Day celebration.
This is part of the city's 250th celebration.
We are celebrating nationally and we were reminded of this when we were in D.C.
We are celebrating the signing, the 250th anniversary of the signing of the Declaration
of Independence.
It's a celebration of the foundation on which all of our freedoms rest.
And so I think it's important to support that and this will be a very special celebration
in District 3.
It will be the Saturday before July 4th.
And so everybody come to Ditto Landing.
There will be fireworks, food trucks, concerts, all kinds of things.
We can all come together to celebrate 250 years of freedom in the United States.
Is there all in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
We have three board appointments to be voted on.
15A is a resolution to reappoint Mark McDaniel to the Educational Building Authority from
Madison Academy to his current seat for a six-year term to expire November 12, 2029.
Motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Maris, second for Mr. Little.
There was a question, Mr. Riley, that was asked at our last meeting regarding why are
we approving an action for a private school?
Could you answer that please?
I looked that up.
I knew generally what the situation was but looked up for the statutory background.
It's found in the Alabama Code section 16, 17, 2 and a few sections following basically
what the Alabama Code provides for or authorizes the incorporation of educational building
authorities, which is what this is, as a public corporation and as political subdivisions
of the state for the purpose of providing ancillary improvements for use in connection
with educational institutions and to invest those authorities with powers that may be
necessary for them to accomplish their purpose.
They include without limitation the power to lease their properties but more importantly,
in my limited experience here, is for issuing interest-bearing revenue bonds to raise money
for building the school buildings and things of that nature.
The city doesn't regulate those entities or participate in their government other than
being the authority or the governmental entity that when the authority is created approves
that and there's a statutory provision which I won't bore everyone with with regard to
that but it's relatively simple and straightforward.
And then they also approve as the governing body the board of directors, the members of
the board of directors as that goes.
So the easy answer is this is state code has set it up for us to do this.
Any other discussion?
All in favor please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
15B is resolution to reappoint Robert Burton to the Educational Building Authority Madison
Academy to his current seat for a six-year term to expire November 10, 2031.
Motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Meredith, second for Mr. Little and this is the same sort of situation.
Any comments?
All in favor please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
15C is a resolution to appoint Ed Banville to the Bingo Review Committee to the seat
previously held by David Driscoll for a two-year term to expire April 8, 2028.
Motion to approve.
Second.
Mr. Meredith, second from Mr. Little.
Any comments?
All in favor please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
We have no board appointment nominations.
Are there any nominations from the floor?
We'll move on then.
We have no hunts for utilities items and 18A is an ordinance authorizing the vacation of
a utility and drainage easement at 13904 Chimney Rock Circle.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Little, second for Mr. Meredith.
Any discussion?
All in favor please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
13, I'm sorry, it's not 13, 18B is an ordinance authorizing the vacation of a portion of a
utility and drainage easement at 12 Shields Road, northeast.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Meredith, second for Mr. Little.
And council members, I don't know, this is not the one.
Any comments?
All in favor please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
18C is a resolution consenting for the vacation of a right of way at 2204 First Street.
2204.
2204, thank you, 2204.
Motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Meredith, second for Mr. Little.
This is the item that we held public hearing for earlier.
Is there any comments, discussion?
All in favor please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
18D is an ordinance vacating the right of way at 2204 First Street.
Motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Meredith, second for Mr. Kling.
Again public hearing was held at 9H.
Any discussion?
All in favor please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
This brings us to 19 unfinished business items for action.
19A is an ordinance to amend.
Section 8.2 appointment rate of ordinance 04-315 personnel policies and procedures manual.
Motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Meredith, second for Mr. Little.
Mr. Hamilton, share with us what we're accomplishing here.
Good evening Council Members, John Hamilton, City Administrator.
So what's before you is an item that I would describe it as corrective.
It's something that we should have brought to you some time ago related to the entry
level step, so on the pay scale, for our police and fire candidates that come in as lateral
transfers.
And so what we mean by lateral is we have a fair number of both officers, police officers
and firefighters who had served in other cities, other either law enforcement or fire service
positions elsewhere and had some number of years of experience, wanted to transfer into
Huntsville and so we hired them in relying on that prior training and that prior experience.
We're bringing in more experienced personnel through this system.
So a few years ago we brought you an action to set by ordinance the minimum entry step
for brand new candidates.
And so that first section you see there on that spreadsheet where it says COH from the
beginning.
So that is what the ordinance currently does for a candidate who has never served previously
in law enforcement or fire brand new rookie coming into our school.
So what happens right now, for both those departments they go through a rigorous hiring
process.
When they start the academy they come in at step eight within the appropriate grade.
And once they've completed all their training, the academy as well as other in-service training
required and they're ready to actually go into full service for our city, they're promoted
to a step 12.
And then like every employee in the city when they hit their one year anniversary they get
a step increase second year anniversary on down.
So that first row is that the ordinance currently reads for police coming in or for police or
firefighters coming in in that circumstance.
What's below that is the current situation for someone who's coming in as a lateral.
So we could have somebody who's in another city, Alabama or otherwise, we have folks
come in from other states but most of our lawyers come from other parts of the state
and they could have up to five years of experience and right now they come in as a step nine.
And that's the way it was prior to the amendment that y'all did a few years ago that set that
top rate.
So when I say it's corrective, we should have at the time that we had you change the
ordinance for brand new candidates, we should have also made a similar change to those coming
in as laterals and we failed to do something.
So this is us coming in trying to fix what we should have already done, quite frankly,
just to be completely transparent with you.
But right now today, as you see a brand new officer who's gone through our academy has
now going his very first day ever serving in law enforcement as a step 12, but someone
who might have served in some other city with five years is coming in as a step nine.
Clearly step nine is not within our system appropriately acknowledging their service.
And we're only bringing in someone who has served well, who's highly qualified that we
very much want to add to our department.
And so we are failing to acknowledge that service in our current structure.
So that's what you see there on the 12, step 12 for brand new as compared to nine, 10 or
11, depending on their years of service in our current system.
And so if you look, you know, five years in, one of somebody who's had all five years of
service with us is now a step 17, someone who had five years of service previously,
now five years less is still only a step 14.
So you see that within our current process, we are failing to acknowledge that prior service
and that experience they brought to our team.
So go into what is proposed, what's before you right now, that top line stays the same.
That is the ordinance as it currently reads for someone who's coming in brand new into
that service and what's before you, it sets a new salary, entry level salary structure
for those that might lateral in.
And you see, we actually break it out by year of service.
So they have to have completed those years.
So for example, somebody has two and a half years, we're going to give them only credit
for four years of service.
So they would come in as two years of service, three, four, five on down through eight.
And what we set out to do here is one, appropriately acknowledge that service that they previously
provided and the experience they're bringing to the team, but also acknowledge that there
is value in someone who has served all those years in Huntsville.
So what this does, so someone who came in brand new to the service with the city of
Huntsville, three years then there'd be a step 15.
Someone who is laterally in with three years of service would be one step behind that.
So we could, I'm giving you one example there.
We could do this for every single one of those examples.
A brand new person coming in with prior service would be one step behind where they would
have been if they'd had all those years with Huntsville.
Acknowledge, and there is a learning curve associated with just learning the community
and things, but we also want to acknowledge that prior service.
Now there's really two layers to this that we've got before you.
One is within our system, within our structure, we believe and we recommend that this better
acknowledges that prior service and that experience they bring to the team and better
aligns their compensation with their fellow police and firefighters that are in our service.
The other thing that it also does is makes us more competitive.
What we have found, and I think y'all are well aware of the challenges of recruiting
folks into public safety across our country right now, but we've experienced that issue
here.
This is an example where we have fallen behind in our compensation package with our surrounding
communities.
And so what this does is much better aligns us with all the other departments that we
partner with that surround us, but they're our partners, but they're also our competitors
in terms of hiring highly qualified people.
And so this will also align us much better in terms of being able to recruit highly qualified
folks, both police and firefighters into our service.
So that is the amendment that's before you is to set that new structure, a new entry
level pay for for lateral transfers.
Thank you.
Questions for Mr. Hamilton.
Mr. Meredith.
Thank you, Madam President.
Could you remind folks how long each of the academies are?
So I probably don't have the exact number of weeks off the top of my head.
I believe the, you know, the, the, we'll start with the fire academies, really two components.
They first, as was discussed earlier, they go through an EMS training.
They have to be fully certified as EMTs and then they go into the fire piece.
And I believe that their total time in the academy is about 18, 19 weeks, something like
that.
And, and then they go into service and obviously there's some then some training that happens
at their station that goes beyond that, which is similar to police, which they're the academy
piece is about 19 weeks and then they go into, you know, a couple of months of their, what
they call their field training.
So they're actually paired up with multiple different senior officers that do in the field
training with them.
So their, their training and their, their, you know, what we'll call their full certification
is not complete until they've graduated both the academy as well as that FTO phase.
Thank you, sir.
And I presume that this is being done in addition to what you said, but to help with recruitment
so that we can up our number of sworn officers and fire fighters.
Could you come back in, I guess a year and let us know how this is, if this is working
for us.
And, and what I can also do, I didn't include in this presentation, but could kind of go
through the historical numbers and we can see where, where, you know, surrounding departments
made changes and we did not where that, that lateral had fallen off.
You go back about four or five years ago and we actually had a very healthy number of laterals
coming in as compared to the last couple of years where that number has gotten really
close to zero.
So this, we expect this to really improve that.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you, madam president.
And as a follow up to that, since we, we approved a new recruiting package last week or new
recruiting consult next week, perhaps in a year have a report altogether on recruiting,
including this.
And I would also say just, you know, you're absolutely correct.
I mean, all of these things are linked to each other.
So this, this helps us with the potential candidates that would be lateral transfers,
but we're also, you know, even a bigger number going after his brand new rookies as well.
And, you know, we, we do know that, that we've got to continue to look at some compensation
things.
I do expect later this year to come back to you all with some additional things that would,
that would affect all, all aspects of the public safety.
So more to go.
We've got a team of folks that are kind of studying that.
So we do have some more things that we need to bring back to you later.
Very good.
Thank you.
I just echo what my colleague said, but this is just great to see.
We all know how competitive the hiring environment is out there and doing anything we can to
sweeten the pot for lack of a better way of putting it to get qualified people in as great.
So that tip you all for working on that.
Thank you.
Anybody else, Mr. I guess I do.
I think this one, we're all pretty much in agreement.
We have a large land area community and having all those police officers and all those firefighters
having to cover all that area, the training, the expertise and what they have to do.
So we certainly want to have them and certainly our manpower and recruiting are very important.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
19 B is an ordinance to thank you, Mr. Hamilton.
19 B is an ordinance to amend ordinance number 89-79 classification salary plan ordinance.
Motion to approve.
Second from Mr. Merritt, second from Mr. Little.
Any questions about this, Mr. Merritt?
I have a question.
What are the two new positions that are being created?
Yes, Byron Thomas, Director of Human Resources.
Yes, one of the positions that we're creating here, let me get that for you, Council.
So one of them is the project funding specialist position going in our engineering department.
Byron actually going to help Kathy Martin as director working with some of the different
contracts and finding and making sure the allocation is correct.
And the other one we had was actually in community development.
We got a real estate record specialist position that we're creating that's working with Scott
Irwin in the community development department.
Are you at liberty to tell us what those price points are?
Yes.
So the funding, project funding specialist is a grade 16.
I'll have to get my chart out.
Grade 16 and then the real estate record specialist is a grade 12.
Thank you, sir.
Yes, sir.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
The motion carries.
19C is an ordinance to amend the budget ordinance number 25-744 to modify the authorized strength
of departments.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Merritt, second from Mr. Little.
Any questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
The motion carries.
19D is an ordinance annexing 2.41 acres of land lying on the west side of Old Big Cove
Road and south of Worley Drive.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Merritt, second from Mr. Kling.
Good evening, councilmembers.
Thomas Newhouse, manager of planning and zoning services.
This item is located west side of Old Big Cove Road and south of Worley Drive.
It is overall 2.41 acres.
It's coming in for a future home, single family home.
That shows the contiguousness.
Any questions for Mr. Newhouse?
Did you say a single family home or single family homes?
A single family home.
Maybe one.
Any other questions?
All in favor, indicate.
I oppose.
Motion carries.
Thank you.
19E is an ordinance to declare certain property surplus unauthorizing the mayor to enter
into a purchasing sale agreement between the City of Huntsville and Averitt Properties
Inc. for the purchase of the same.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Merritt, second from Mr. Liddell.
Mr. Davis.
Good evening, councilmembers.
Shane Davis, director of urban economic development.
So councilmembers, this is property that the city purchased back in 2018.
It's actually a small sliver of the Eli Lilly site, so it's at exit three.
So in working with Averitt Express, they've continued to grow certainly with the logistics
of target distribution, both Amazon facilities, Mazda Toyota, the list players, the list goes
on and on.
So they've continued to grow.
So they have a piece of property that fronts Greenbrier Parkway and one that fronts Alabama
20.
They would like to connect those.
So this little four-acre piece would connect both of those properties into an L shape.
But what it really does for us is the amount of truck traffic that they are having to do
through that intersection to go from one piece of property to the other to transfer tractor
trailer trailers, all that can handle internally, which takes a tremendous amount of truck traffic
in that congested intersection there at exit three and creates some safety.
So should you approve tonight, we would sell them four acres.
The purchase process, $60,000 an acre for $240,000.
So we did get the appraisal.
When we bought the property back in the day, it was around $38,000.
Any questions, Mr. Mayor?
Thank you, Madam President.
Mr. Davis, I assume that's market value?
Yes, based on appraisal, that's what we were able to do.
Just wanted to make sure.
Yeah, absolutely.
Thanks for explaining why the mayor was needed in this.
I was puzzled as to why the mayor would be a part of Averitt's property.
I wish you had a graphic to show me.
I'm very familiar with that area.
But when you're talking about them taking truck traffic off or reducing the inconvenience
of truck traffic, where is that traffic going to be coming out?
Is it going to be coming out closer to the lights by, say, the Redstone Federal Credit
Union or further south down toward, say, the target distribution center?
Because I assume they're not going to be coming on to 20.
I hope this helps illustrate.
You see the two red boxes that have the logo of Averitt Express.
The green shaded area is the area that you're voting on to sell.
You can see how now they have an interconnected campus.
If you see the red box on the left is front of Greenbrier Parkway, kind of the reverse
L shape that actually has egress from Alabama 20.
So as they get tractor trailers that need to come around to the Greenbrier Parkway,
so they're having to get ferry back and forth through that intersection daily, multiple
trips.
Through which intersection specifically?
So the intersection that you see, Alabama 20, where it comes out on green.
So it is 20.
Well, yes.
So let's see if this arrow will actually show up on screen.
So yes, it does.
So I can get it here.
So if you see that intersection here with this arrow, so they are coming up and down
in this direction.
And there is a light there, right?
There is.
And with all the growth, this is a very active intersection.
So to be able to reduce the number of 53 foot tractor trailers making multiple left hand,
right hand turns, now that can happen internally to their campus is a great safety benefit
for the traveling public and 14,000 jobs of double shifts that we've created out in this
area.
What's across the street?
Is that Polaris?
That's Target.
That is the Target distribution.
Yes, sir.
Thank you, sir.
You're welcome.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
19F is an ordinance declaring certain equipment surplus and to be sold at public auction.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little.
Second.
Second from Mr. Merida.
Are there any questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
This brings us to item 20, new items for consideration or action.
These items will be approved in one motion unless any member of the council wishes to
remove an item for discussion.
The reading of each item will be waived unless a council member requests otherwise.
Council members have informed me that they would like to hold the following items.
Excuse me, I need to add E.
Council members wish to hold items C, 20D, 20E, 20G, 20O, 20Q, 20S, 20T, 20U, 20Z, and
20AB.
Are there any other items any council member would like to hold?
Not much left.
Yeah.
Good point.
We're going to be here for a while.
So the chair would make the motion to consolidate and approve items 20A and B, 20F, 20H, 2N,
20P, 20R, 20V, 2X, 20E.
To Y.
I'm going to put my glasses on.
V to Y.
Right.
20AA and 20AC and AD.
Yes ma'am.
Second.
Second for Mr. Mayor.
If all in favor please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
We will go then to 20C for separate consideration.
20C is a resolution authorizing the President or President Pro Tem of the City Council to
make written or other submissions as required, give notices or notifications, and represent
the counseling meetings as required by Alabama Code Section 11-99-1 with respect to consideration
of tentatively named TIF-9 on behalf of the City Council of the City of Huntsville, Alabama.
Is there a motion to approve?
So moved.
Motion for Mr. Kling, second for Mr. Little.
You're going to be hearing a lot about TIF-9 in the coming month or so.
So Mr. Davis, would you please introduce this for us?
Thank you Madam President.
Shane Davis, Director of Urban and Economic Affairs.
So you are correct.
So tonight you have approved a set of public hearings for May 14th to consider a project
plan for a new TIF district.
So what I want to do is walk Council through items C and D and answer any questions.
So give a very.
If I can interject.
Absolutely.
You can't talk about D.
Item C first.
If you'll just let us know about item C.
Okay.
So item C gives you as a Council President or Pro Tem by state law to set dates to go
through to create a TIF district.
Very simple.
Thank you.
Any questions for Mr. Davis?
I have a question.
So my initial thought is why doesn't this fall to the Mayor?
Why are we asking the President and the Pro Tem to do this when this is something of,
truly of the administration?
So that would be item D and I'll get to that.
Your question will be related to item D.
Well the question is being asked under this particular issue.
Okay.
This particular one.
So go ahead.
Yes sir.
We're happy to.
That's why we wanted to go through these.
So under the state law, under the TIF statute, there's three primary things that the City
Council has to do for the administration or my department under the guise of the Mayor
to go create any TIF district.
Certainly we've done a lot of these in the city.
Your district has been a benefactor in recent years, right?
And good things have come out of those, right?
So tonight you've already passed one step and that's to go create a public hearing.
That public hearing would unveil by the administration proposed plan or proposed projects that would
be in that TIF district.
Certainly it will be this council's determination to choose to move forward with those projects
or that project plan.
The second step is this council must authorize the council president or pro tem because there's
a series of public meetings, public notifications both in the legal paper, there's communication
with the Madison County Commission in this case because this will be in Madison County
such to provide those notices.
So state law says that we must designate the president or the pro tem or the council at
that current time to have the authority to allow the legal department or direct legal
department per schedule.
So there's calendar days within the state statute things must occur.
Some of those may occur on a council meeting, some may not, but it's simply a public notice
of a public hearing that's coming or just to get a legal ad run.
It must run two times maybe in a paper so someone has to sign for that to run.
So that's what this item C that you're voting on is.
Item D to answer your question, I want to go through each of these very quickly.
We can't do D yet.
Okay.
I appreciate you're trying to be consolidated.
I haven't answered your question yet but I will answer it in D.
No go ahead then if you have an answer.
I thought you did.
No okay I'm sorry.
So you asked why the mayor.
So under the statute the third thing that in setting a TIF district is this council
body must direct the administration to go and create a TIF project plan to present to
this council to consider.
That is answering your question, you know why the mayor?
That's what item D and that's all per state law.
You had me with the prior reasoning being that we're talking about notifications for
public meetings.
That makes sense.
The other part not so much but if it's state law it's state law.
I have been I guess involved with TIF since coming on council but this is the first time
I've been involved at the creation level.
So it's the first time I'm seeing President Pro Tem being involved in having to do something
other than voting for it related to a TIF.
So it's nothing about the President Pro Tem is doing nothing to create the district at
all.
That will be this council body as a whole.
Right because TIFs are coming from the administration not necessarily.
So we have to present this body a project plan.
We've not done that yet and should you vote on C and D we will do that on May 14th.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome sir.
I appreciate the level of your answer.
Thank you sir.
And I think we will have more clarity as we go on to the next item.
Any other questions?
All in favor please indicate aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
20D is a resolution authorizing the City of Huntsville Department of Urban Health Development
to prepare a project plan for the development of a proposed tax increment financing district
tentatively named TIF 9 which district encompasses approximately 3689.51 acres more or less in
accordance with Alabama Code section 11-99-1.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Meredith, second from Mr. Little.
Now Mr. Davis if you will enlighten us.
Thank you Madam President.
So to further that discussion that Councilman Merrith really wants to dive into and so do
I and he's asked good questions.
So per state law this should you vote for this you are directing the mayor, the administration
and the team behind that the departments to come before this body this public body and
present you a proposed TIF 9 district plan.
So what would that entail?
So that would entail project plans, public improvements for the most recent TIF 6 and
7 that we've seen predominantly in district 5 is included roads and it's included utilities
and you know what we've done in the city in and around Huntsville High we've helped build
educational facilities for Huntsville City Schools.
It's all got to be public improvement.
So should you move forward with this what the administration will do is bring you a
plan for this boundary that would be created just under 3700 acres in predominantly their
central business district plus or minus you know a few blocks north and south we'll go
and start looking at and why are we asking for this or you know trying to partner with
the City Council to do this.
We're seeing significant private investment downtown.
We are always needing public improvements.
TIF districts are a great way to allow private new development that sometimes can be taxing
on our public infrastructure to help pay for that.
Rather than take an area that we may want to build a road in one of your districts and
we say hey downtown is growing we need a public parking garage or we want to connect a green
way or whatever that case may be we're going to delay your road project because we want
to shift those funds to help support this.
The TIF district allows us not to have to do that.
We're able to take the future proceeds from these developments not taking the tax base
away from our schools or county or city budget on all existing taxes that are being paid
within that district.
Those go the tax recipients as they are today.
So we're not taking any revenue away from anyone to go create this dish.
What we're taking is creating a boundary of private investment that we know that is occurring
that will come on the tax rolls and allow that revenue to help pay for public infrastructure
within that area that that investment is occurring.
So that's the plan we need to come back to this body and publicly and explain to you
and say based on the great investments and momentum that we're seeing downtown is take
advantage of that and advance public infrastructure within this boundary.
I hope I'm answering any questions I hope that gives a brief overview of what you're
voting on.
And your question was one of the mayor you're about to go direct the mayor.
Yeah.
Mr. Davis Mr. Meredith you have any other questions.
Just a comment I had no I know a little about going and I had no idea it was that many acres.
That's a lot of acres.
Yeah and for TIF district it's actually a pretty balanced of what we've done the past
TIF seven in your district is much much larger than that TIF six was about this a little
larger.
It's closed out accelerated.
But the reason we do this is one that some of the investment we know is coming when we
capture that.
But also based on this investment a lot of times when we go do these TIF boundaries is
we know things of public infrastructure that you want the public wants to see what we want
to we want to go build that.
So so it's this balance of capturing that private investments currently downtown and
how can we take that and take those revenues to advance public infrastructure we all need
this community and you can't just I couldn't go all the way the Tennessee River all the
way to Alabama and then with this.
But we try to stretch that envelope as much as we can to go do as much public improvements
take advantage of this moment of growth in our city.
Good question.
Thank you.
Madam President I believe Mr. Cling has a question the investment in central city.
I want to get close to your microphone.
I think there'd be a problem here.
I like the investment in the central portion of the city.
All these other guys they get to talk about their outline annexations and everything and
I'm the guy I'm sort of like literally the guy in the middle.
But it is good because you know we are doing a lot of good revitalization for downtown
and the central portion of the city.
We talk about quality of life and you know we talk about doing new things but at the
same time we can take care of me the areas that we have for the people that we already
have just a little bit nicer and do some things that can help show off Huntsville.
So I think that's great.
One question and I think I know the answer and I think it's a good answer but the history
that we've had with tips.
Don't they all haven't they all worked out financially where you know everything got
paid off the way it was supposed to.
Yeah so you may think this is TIF 9 would be the you know the ninth TIF actually would
be the tenth there's a eight coming for district five maybe that we're trying to work on also
but I've been here 25 years with the city.
I cannot recall a TIF district that has with the full term if you will the 20 years they've
all accelerated and paid off well so we're very conservative with these.
Certainly we want to get public infrastructure built that we need but we also want to get
that those bonds paid off with these new investments and soon as those are paid off take that new
revenue that has been created in that district and get it to the tax recipients one city
hall private I mean county government Massie County government and then our school system.
So so if you look at the ones we just recently closed off I think the mayor and the council
had Huntsville City Schools here we presented them a check.
I remember when we paid off TIF 6 I called chairman Daly Limestone County and said hey
just want you know we're about to pay this off and I gave him his proceeds amount he
said man we could really use that and I said well that's forever you know you'll get that
next year and here's the lifestyle County schools so everyone wins you know it's a little
moment in time but you got to give up some revenue but everyone that I've seen close
out that little bit you gave up for that short duration is typically a 2x 3x or 4x return
pretty quickly took to all of our tax recipients.
Any other questions is there a limit to the number of TIF districts we can enact.
There is not and they can overlap so actually in council members district TIF 6 and 7.
They overlap somewhat.
Interesting any other questions all in favor please indicate aye.
Opposed motion carries we will be hearing more about TIF 9 in the future.
Council members thank you we'll thank you Shane give you some preliminary data on that
count May 14 public hearing thank you very good thank you so much.
20E is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter an agreement between the City of
Huntsville and New Stone Commons LLC for the development of a New Stone Commons with home
investment partnerships program American rescue plan home art funds.
Their motion to approve second motion for Mr. Little second for Mr. Merida.
Mr. Irwin yes council member Scott Irwin community development department thank you for opportunity
to hold this to discuss it because whenever we have opportunities to increase our affordable
housing stock the Huntsville will come before you and actually for a brag on that a little
bit so this is 20E is a final agreement to use home ARP American rescue plan funds to
develop New Stone Commons and affordable multifamily project located at 3450 Venona Avenue.
Cities are able to create affordable housing by using grant funds to fill the funding gap.
This is the gap between the construction cost and the lower rental income usually generated
by projects based on the affordable rental guidelines.
Huntsville like many cities rarely directly build instead we act as a conduit we use grant
money to partially fund the development to create affordable housing options.
This project is a collaborative project between the City of Huntsville the Alabama Housing
Finance Authority and Neighborhood Concepts to create 42 affordable multifamily units
that will serve families who will reside in the Venona neighborhood.
The total development cost for this is $15.9 million.
The home ARP program funds supporting this project you are asked to commit tonight is
$2,303,834.
Questions for Mr. Irwin.
Is this the property over on Monroe you might have said that?
It is not this is on Venona up off of Maston Lake.
Okay sorry all right thank you.
Any other questions?
How are we doing as far as affordable housing needs in this community?
I hear of needs and then I see things that say we are doing good in a magazine article
here and there but what is your evaluation of where we stand at this point?
Comparing Huntsville against comparable cities around the nation we are toward the top obviously
with a lot we have done.
But what we do daily is work to try to bring new projects like this into Huntsville that
create the opportunity for families to have lower income lower based on lower income still
have quality affordable housing.
So this is one more effort in doing that whether we are doing single family development, homeownership
assistance programs or developing an increase in the stock of affordable rental housing
which you have seen other projects and as Mr. Little mentioned on Meridian Commons which
is to be more information on that to be coming.
But we are very intentional and I believe we are actually making differences.
Between the supply is a big issue but also things under the planning department and other
tools at the disposal of that department will actually continue to provide more available
affordable housing.
Thank you.
Mr. Davis would you like to add to that?
Just very quickly Council Members I am sorry but to add to and answer your question Councilman
Cline kudos to the planning staff and engineering staff of modifying some of our zoning ordinance
to get different lot sizes and setbacks such to introduce new price point housing.
So we have worked with our developers and our home builders to say hey what do you need
to see from a zoning perspective and a lot creation lot size to create price points of
X, Y and Z and deliver that into our community.
So that is that partnership to make sure we can get price points in the upper 2's and
mid 3's and so on.
Some of that has taken us to change the way we allow business to be conducted.
So as Scott said we are turning every knob we can to try to provide as much broad based
of affordability as we know how.
Thank you.
Madam President while I get you there Mr. Davis is that why I am saying in my district
houses really packed in there really tight.
You are.
Ok.
He brings up a great point.
So you think about for sale product.
You know Mill Creek is a for rent product and it is income based but a for sale new home
someone wants to purchase the American dream.
Think about what you can control and you can't control.
Labor cost can't control that.
You know you have got to pay the right wage to get the right people on site to go construct
a house.
Land materials that is a market rate that no community no government can control.
So the other piece is land cost.
We don't control the land market of a private transaction so all those are fixed.
So how can we adjust because that all gets passed on in that house.
So how can we make a narrower lot so there is not so much passed through that land cost.
You get a little few more lots and you can spread out those fixed costs.
So that is why you are seeing some side yard setbacks a little closer.
We didn't want to give up rear yards as much.
We want people to have a back yard and a front yard.
So just really work in those lot sizes and shapes just to spread that cost and get it
a little lower.
Thank you sir.
You are welcome.
We have had a good conversation here about affordable housing and I permitted it as a
point of information but we need to get back to the actual agenda item is on Newstone Commons.
Does anyone have any questions about that?
All in favor please indicate aye.
Opposed the motion carries.
20G is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter into an agreement between the City
of Huntsville and Community Action Partnership of Huntsville Madison and Limestone Counties
Inc. for the use of a DECA fiscal year 25 emergency solutions grant funding.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Mayor to second from the Chair.
Mr. Erwin.
Yes Council Members this is the agreement between the City and Community Action Partnership
of Huntsville Madison and Limestone Counties.
This is for the FY25 emergency solution grant funding which provides homeless service providers
and homeless resources within our community.
This particular agency is receiving a $25,000 agreement for the homeless prevention to actually
keep individuals from becoming unhoused.
Are there questions for Mr. Erwin?
Any discussion?
All those in favor please indicate aye.
Opposed the motion carries.
Thank you Council Members.
All right we'll go to 20.
20.
Oh 20.
Oh is a resolution authorizing there to enter into a contract between the City of Huntsville
and apparent low bidder Rogers Group Inc. for the Old Menorovia Road improvements base
bid and option number one project number 71 dash 21 dash RD 07.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Mayor to second from Mr. Little.
Are there questions or comments that anyone has?
Question.
Mr. Mayor.
Welcome back Mr. Davis could you tell me what the specific improvements are going to be
for the Old Menorovia?
Yes sir.
Yes so these are the planned improvements we've been working on for a couple years now.
So we're creating a complete street from University Drive South into Research Park Corporate Drive
so it's on the east side of the Mid-City District so creating some multi-use paths that will
get you into Research Park connect to some internal paths to Mid-City and also get you
to the Ryan Amphitheater and through the park so from a pedestrian standpoint upgrading
lighting along Old Menorovia.
The character and the condition of that area has changed drastically from a regional 1.1
million square feet mall where we're trying to get you know 10 or 15 thousand cars into
a retail center and back out.
Now it's a much more walkable area and one of our northern gateway entrances to Research
Park East so you know back when Master Square Mall was there it's almost six lanes wide
certainly doesn't need that so we want to slow traffic down.
We've seen some high speeds in that short section so we're doing some on-street parking
and then heavy landscape more pedestrian facilities bike lane facilities really to just change
the character of that area as you go into Research Park in the Mid-City District more
conducive to where it acts today rather than a big regional mall there.
So excuse me it's going to essentially be a road diet we're going to reduce the number
of lanes coming through we're going to add more walkability I assume this is going to
tie into some sort of greenway or bike trail or something into UAH as well correct?
That's right so the next phase would be to take Sanderson back into UAH the Executive
Plaza master plan that UH is working on so all this has been kind of master planned if
you will and rolling it out as development and the plans like you just mentioned UH starts
to come out so this Old Monrovia is the first phase over the next few years you'll see us
continue to kind of move towards Wind Drive and then on in towards you know Holmes Avenue
the complete street from downtown to UAH is part of that linkage so this is one of those
pieces just to really make it more pedestrian friendly you know Research Park in that area
is 60 years old and a lot of things have remained unchanged from public road infrastructure
and we're much more mobile society in the way we're starting to allow different uses
in Research Park East I mean you've seen what's happened around the cyber school we've got
now livability in Research Park East so just really updating the way people use that area
of the city.
One suggestion I know my constituents would want me to ask or make a comment on your way
is can we not have back end diagonal parking on this street just let's just do it either
pull in or parallel the back end thing is.
Yeah so you know it was something this community did not see I'm starting to see in the Mid
City District people getting used to it and really the reason we use it you're starting
across the US start to see angle parking convert to this it's actually a safer movement if
you really look at regular slant parking is more of a European style certainly we are
on the left side of the car driving so you get those long you know kind of angle parking
and the first thing you're trying to do is back out and the car besides you you're on
the wrong side of car C so we've done that we knew it would be a learning curve for this
road project is parallel because the angle parking would have just took too much of the
pavement up we wanted to make capacity to get through but you know we had put up some
signage in Mid City and I'm proud to say the more I'm out there the less I see people
parked in on the wrong way so.
Thank you final question what's strictly on on old Monrovia improvement what's the timeline
on?
So should you approve this to tonight Engineering Department would then schedule a pre construction
meeting sometime next week and then issue the notice to proceed the contractor and about
six months I would they should finish by the end of the year.
Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
Any other comments or questions all in favor please indicate.
Aye.
That's all in favor please stand.
Thank you.
20 Q is a resolution authorized mayor to enter into fixed price agreement between Steve Hunsell
and Butler construction company for the public safety facility renovation motion to approve
motion from Mr. Maris second from Mr. Little Mr. Wilkinson.
Good evening Ricky Wilkinson director of general services so this is a construction services
contract with Butler construction company for the public safety facility renovation
the amount of this contract is three million one hundred seventy seven thousand three hundred
dollars.
This is renovation of the former Bailey Cove library location in South Huntsville will primarily
be converted into office space for HPD.
This will allow us to vacate some lease space that they're currently occupying.
It's a one year construction contract.
Any questions.
Mr. Merritt if it's if we're going to relinquish some leases how much are we going to capture
from those leases that we're not paying out on.
I don't I don't have the exact numbers in front of me.
I'm certainly happy to be ballpark.
If you're not comfortable you can do it later but yeah let me let me work on that for you
so I can give you an accurate number.
That's that's fine.
It will be a savings obviously for the lease dollars going out there will be a savings
back to the city to help help with this but probably nowhere close to over three million
not certainly in the initial near term but for the life of the building I think we would
probably you know be comparable to that plus you consider the value of the building being
occupied versus it being vacant currently.
It's not a bad deal and I know we're talking about renovations and you did mention office
space so we're going to essentially gut the interior of this and produce office space.
So what's kind of interesting this was a library branch there's not a whole lot to be gutted.
Libraries are obviously open for very minimal office space enclosed so really this is primarily
a build out there's not a whole lot to get just based on the previous use of the building.
Thank you sir.
Yes sir.
Mr. Liddell.
Let's make sure this is going to be this is a new South precinct.
This is not the new South precinct so we did evaluate this unfortunately there's not enough
not enough parking not enough building space for the South police precinct.
Council did approve obviously some purchase for a future South police precinct last year
timeline to be determined on that.
No I got it.
Dr. Robinson helped me understand.
Any other questions?
All in favor please.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you.
20S is a resolution to adjust the salaries of employees in certain positions in assigned
departments.
Motion to approve.
Motion.
Second.
Motion from Mr. Meredith second from Mr. Liddell.
Yes Byron Thomas director of human resources.
This is a routine resolution where we adjust the steps of employees within a certain department
based upon some time promotions where another employees come in and we want to evaluate
the employee make sure we have them equitable.
Any questions or comments?
I have questions.
Can you tell share with us which employees are going to I presume get this increase?
Yes sir.
On the resolution that does identify the Ms. Betty Collins our parking attendant coordinator
and also Mr. Lewis Whiteside in parking as well.
Thank you very much.
In honor of administrative assistance can we look at the council and see what we can
do about getting them.
And there are procedures for that if we do an audit.
Formally requesting an audit.
Again that's not germane to this discussion.
So do you have questions regarding this item?
All in favor please.
Aye.
Opposed?
20T is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter into a confidentiality and non-disclosure
agreement between the premise health employer solutions LLC, Blue Cross Blue Shield of Alabama,
Deerwalk Inc. doing business as Cedar Gate Technologies and the city of Huntsville.
Chair makes the motion.
I second.
Second from Mr. Little.
Yes Byron Thomas director of human resources.
This is a routine agreement between city, Blue Cross, premise health, health and wellness
center they share data just to make sure it maintains confidentiality and non-disclosure.
Mr. Merida.
Question that is pertinent to this particular issue.
Why don't we have the responsibility to approve all the non-disclosure agreements?
Well this is a combined one it includes all of the agencies entities on this one agreement.
So whenever we have a separate contract for them we will put a what we call the business
associate agreement in there and you will approve it at this time.
These organizations share data with the collective agency doing business like Cedar Gate.
So this is just a routine what we've done in the past to make sure they all understand
that information needs to be maintained.
I guess the question then needs to go to legal and you know this is the first time in all
of the non-disclosure agreements that the mayor enters into why is this the only one
that has come before the council half of them we don't even know exist.
I'll be happy to look into it I don't have an answer for you right now.
Please let's do that.
Thank you.
Anyone else have a question.
All in favor please indicate.
I oppose the motion carries.
I would abstain on this one.
All right but the records show that Mr. Meredith has abstained other council members voted
in favor.
20U is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter into a three-year renewal agreement
between the city of Huntsville and Microsoft through software house international SHI identified
as licensing program signature form and in customer agreement for Microsoft support services.
Chair moves for approval.
I second.
Second by Mr. Little.
Good evening council members.
I'm Gene Newell director of information technology services.
What you have in front of you is a renewal agreement.
Generally in the past this has been done in two separate entries but what we did is we
combined it this year because we were able to realize our savings with that.
So with the Microsoft agreement this is probably our fourth this is our fourth iteration of
renewing this particular agreement and the cost in front of you is the enterprise agreement
is $3,509,187.58 and the unified support agreement is $1,090,338.35 with a grand total of $4,599,525.93.
Questions Mr. Meredith?
Yes.
It's an awful lot of money.
What are the taxpayers getting for this?
Basically Microsoft is a critical business process, right?
It's what we use within the city to handle all our day-to-day processes.
What we get is the functionality of the Microsoft products which would be your Word, your Excel
which is a flagship standard when it comes to accounting practices.
You get your PowerPoint solution and also the identity management.
This is something that is critical within the city to maintain day-to-day operations.
So it's nothing new.
We're not getting anything additional to what we have always had.
Well there is because what happens is with the advances of technology and things, AI,
there are certain levels of licensing that we have to improve.
Like we were running a G3 licenses in the past but right now we have to upgrade the
G5 licenses because one of the add-ons that we were going to add to the G3 licenses was
data management and data classification.
And the reason why we had to implement that feature set is because of the implementation
of technological advances like artificial intelligence.
So when we looked at adding that feature set to the G3 license, the pricing was equal to
purchasing the G5 license.
Now when we get the G5 license, we get a lot more features with that for the same price.
I can get technical.
I'll be glad to explain it to you.
But we get like into entropy to categorization which is the advanced identity management
and protection services that Microsoft offers for our data and our infrastructure.
We get the data classification aspect of it.
We get Intune which is mobile device management which allows us to keep control of all the
mobile devices that people have around laptops, cell phones, whether it's an iPhone or an
Android.
So it was just more beneficial to actually purchase the G5 licenses and get all those
extra feature sets as well as the advanced analytics that we get to report on the use
of our technologies that we're paying for.
What I guess percentage of this is related to artificial intelligence?
The artificial intelligence piece of this is a co-pilot licensing.
And right now we don't have, that's a separate licensing that we purchased.
And the pricing, the licensing model for Microsoft is dynamic.
Generally what this handles is all our employees.
But when people want to get into like co-pilot, it's a separate license that we purchase and
we are stair stepping that.
We're not just going to fully deploy it because we have to put up these barriers, the guidelines,
because the implementation is very sensitive on how we want to do this.
So we buy them piecemeal as we utilize that.
So this is not going to implement AI through the entire infrastructure of the city.
What this is is this is going to afford us the technology that we need that when we do
implement it, we can maintain controls of it.
Thank you, sir.
You're welcome.
Madam President.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you.
20Z is a resolution consenting to certain actions of the Huntsville and Madison County
Railroad Authority with regards to purchasing locomotives and other equipment to facilitate
rail operations.
Move for approval.
Second.
Motion for Mr. Kling, second for Mr. Little.
Council members, you have any questions?
I have a question.
Define certain actions.
So if there's someone who would like to comment to this.
I believe we have the board chair of the Huntsville Madison County Railroad, Mr. Lum, welcome.
If you'd like to introduce yourself for the record and then tell us why you need this
resolution approved by the Huntsville City Council.
Good evening, council members.
As stated, Mark Lum, chairman of the Huntsville Madison County Railroad Authority Board of
Directors.
The original 1984 authorizing legislation requires us to come before the city council
in the Madison County Commission for any capital expenditure in excess of $100,000.
I don't think $100,000 bought much in 1984.
It sure doesn't buy much in 2026.
This accrues no financial liability to the city or the county in any way.
And what we are anticipating is the need for at least one, possibly two new locomotives
or actually additional locomotives.
Right now on the used market, they go for about $250,000 apiece.
We are also anticipating the need should St. Gobain come back up on line that of course
is the company at the end of the line, the reason the railroad was created back in 1984,
chiefly to buy some material handling equipment should they need us to transload.
So we are asking for approval and ahead of the need to purchase so if we find a good
deal we can go ahead and act immediately.
And I would add to that in addition to seeking or requiring approval by the city council,
the enabling documentation also requires approval from the county commission.
It does.
That will take place at their next meeting.
Again, what are certain actions?
Are you talking about negotiating or what are you talking about actually doing?
This is about approving debt.
Okay, that's not a certain action.
This is approving debt, we are required to approve debt just like council utilities and
then that debt is going to fund potentially two locomotives and a conveyor.
Okay but describing it as certain actions is very...
Agreed the wording might have been a little vague.
Sounds great.
Thank you, Mark.
Okay, any other questions?
Yes.
Yes, Mark.
We got two train items on the agenda tonight.
I'm all geeked up.
I'm just curious if the power you're thinking about buying, do you know what it is yet?
Similar to the power we already have.
Okay.
I don't want to get too technical.
But you can tell, is it Jeeps?
I'm sorry?
Jeeps?
No, they're General Electric.
Okay, all right.
That's all I have.
Yes, he really is a train nerd.
Anybody else?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you, Mark, for being here tonight.
And then 20 AB is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter into an agreement with
DBECO North America Inc. for professional services related to the Huntsville area MPO
inner city passenger rail study.
Motion to approve.
Second.
Motion by Mr. Mayor, second by Mr. Klink.
Good evening, council.
Thank you for having me.
Dennis Madsen with the planning department.
I'm going to talk real quickly about the item and then entertain any questions.
So this is an MPO study.
I want to start with a quick graphic.
This graphic is a clip from the national rail map.
It was a plan that was updated in 2021.
As you can see, let's see if I can zoom in a little closer.
There's a certain city in Alabama that has not included on the national rail plan.
This was not necessarily a deliberate oversight by the Federal Government when they updated
the plan.
They were simply taking existing State rail plans and incorporating them.
But we do think that's something that needs to be remedied going forward, especially as
the government continues to consider the expansion of passenger rail nationwide or even on a
regional basis.
So the MPO issued an RFP.
It closed on December 2nd.
We had four proposals.
DBECO, DB is Deutsche Bahn.
They know trains.
They were the highest scoring return.
The total contract cost is $348,874.55.
Those are all exclusively MPO funds.
They're PL funds specifically used for conducting studies like this.
The goals, the key objectives are really look at existing trips from or among Huntsville
and other regional communities to recommend corridors that would require subsequent study.
Look at potential grant sources.
This is not the type of project, I think you can imagine, that is funded or really facilitated
at the municipal level.
This is something that typically involves Federal Government, State Government.
This is a significant infrastructure investment.
This is really the first step in that.
So we're looking at taking about 16 to 18 months to complete that.
We do want to make sure we're fairly clear.
This does not involve Huntsville, Madison and County Railroad Authority.
This does not involve local transit.
When we talk about intercity rail, we're talking about Amtrak style rail.
We're talking city to city rail.
So it's not light rail.
We have some questions about that as well.
If you're thinking street cars or things like that that are moving locally, that's not those.
And it also does not involve the Huntsville Depot because I know we've been talking about
planning for that.
This is not that.
This is really looking regionally.
We do have a couple of peer cities, Chattanooga and Birmingham, that both in the last six
months stated an intent to engage in passenger rail studies, mostly geared towards linking
them with Atlanta.
But this was an effort.
I think we want to be clear that this study will not facilitate passenger rail by itself.
What this study does is that as the federal government and the other related transit agencies
start to have those discussions, that Huntsville is included and is at the table in any development
of a national passenger rail plan.
Are you going to be advocating any specific routes?
I know you've got up here Birmingham, Nashville, but like the Huntsville, Nashville, Huntsville,
Birmingham, Mobile.
I have my own personal places that I'd like to go.
I would love to see a beach train because we spend, but no, this actually we will pull
back.
We are relying on experts to actually look at this and say, what are the ones that make
sense?
We don't give them any parameters as far as this.
You work for us.
This is what we want.
Precisely.
They're going to look at data and they're going to see what makes sense.
And a lot of it has to be what's economically viable as well.
You want to run a route that actually makes sense, that moves people.
Other questions, Mr. Mayor.
Someone mentioned earlier public comment about high speed rail.
This is not going to be high speed rail.
It might be.
That's so early in the discussion.
What we frequently hear of discussed in American national rail circles is not necessarily high
speed rail, but we call high efficiency rail.
Where you're looking at quick movements, city to city, not a lot of intermediate stops.
So that you could make it, say, from Huntsville to Mobile in three hours.
You are moving, say, faster than traffic, but no, you're not talking as much as I love
the videos of them.
And Dave and I have talked a little bit about this.
We're not talking maglev or the 300 kilometer an hour trains.
Yeah.
Okay.
So if we talk about the MPO in here, how much is the MPO putting up for this?
The MPO, this is all MPO funds.
This is all PL funds.
It is exclusively MPO funds that are going to fund the study.
Okay.
The notations we have on here says it costs.
Yeah.
That's what I understood.
That is incorrect.
It's all MPO planning funds.
Awesome.
Thank you for that clarification.
Thank you, Madam President.
Mr. Kling.
I'm sorry, Mr. Little.
I assume the Southern Rail Commission is still in existence.
They are.
Do we have a North Alabama representation on there?
It seemed like there was some chatter about that a while back.
There had been.
I hadn't heard anything since then.
I do believe we have representation on there.
I do not know who it is.
That would actually come out of the mayor's office.
I can check with him and get you an answer and see.
That map is troubling to me is we're the biggest and best city in the whole state.
It should be there.
So I'm glad that we're a part of this.
Like we said, we have a seat at the table, whether this is 10 or 20 years from now.
When you are seeing rail movement regionally in other spots, there's what's known as the
Mardi Gras line, which goes from Mobile to New Orleans, which has been running, I think,
since August last year, has exceeded 100,000 riders.
So there is demand out there for it.
We are, and again, I have to really caution us.
This is the first step of a fairly long journey, much of which is outside our control.
We just want to make sure that when the discussion of inner city passenger rail is being advanced,
that we have a seat at the table.
Right.
Thank you, Madam President.
Ms. Watkins.
Okay.
So after the study, you receive it back.
What's the next steps?
What do you plan on doing with the study?
So the next steps are, depending on what comes out of the study, look at investigating corridors
in more detail.
They also talk about potential funding mechanisms.
But again, I hesitate to put too much detail on that because that's really what the study
is going to do is say, what are your logical next steps?
What are the routes that make sense?
Do you need to engage State agencies, Federal agencies?
Who would actually be the big partner in facilitating this?
And I know as an MPO representative, you'll probably be one of the first to see it because
this will end up being reported to the MPO.
Will this go into the MPO plan as a visionary project?
That may take a while.
It could be part of kind of an appendix the way we have things like the bike plan.
It may fall into it in kind of a similar fashion.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
That concludes, oh, let's see, well now that includes items for action tonight.
We will move on to new business items for introduction.
These items will not be considered tonight.
They will be considered at the May 14th meeting.
21A is an introduction of an ordinance to amend ordinance number 94-523, which establishes
precinct boundary lines for municipal elections.
21B is an introduction of an ordinance to amend Chapter 3, alcoholic beverages, Article
3 of the Code of Ordinances of the City of Huntsville, subsection A of Section 3-133,
hours of sale and operations.
21C is the introduction of an ordinance annexing 2.47 acres of land lying on the south side
of Highway 20 and east of Greenbrier Parkway.
That concludes the business of the City.
The next item on our agenda is second roster public comments.
We have 12 people signed up.
So I would like to ask a point of privilege that we take a break for five minutes and
we'll come back for the citizen comments.
So we will come back at 846.
Okay, it is 846 and we will reconvene this session of the Huntsville City Council if
we could please have order.
We are going to reconvene this session of the Huntsville City Council if we could have
everyone's attention please.
We will go on now with second roster communications.
I will begin with, well let me read my little preamble here.
This portion of the meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address the Council on
matters relating to city business, whether or not such items are on the meeting agenda.
Individuals have signed up to speak on the second public comments roster prior to the
meeting and when your name is called please approach the microphone, state your name,
address and city of residence.
I will also call the name of the person following so please be prepared to come to the microphone.
Each speaker may address the Council for three minutes.
Speakers shall refrain from entering into a dialogue with Council members or city staff
and from making comments regarding good name and character of any individual.
The first person to sign up is Ashley Douthit.
Ashley Douthit will be followed by Robert Clifton.
Is Ashley Douthit here?
All right well I assume they're taking care of whatever her comments were.
So Mr. Clifton, is Robert Clifton here and Mr. Clifton will be followed by Christopher
Leoy.
My name is Robert Clifton, 101 Fowler Creek Way, Hazel Green, Alabama 35750.
I'm really new at all this.
I really, I'm just trying to figure out which way to go to try to get some results.
I come to a dead end, people scared to death, people don't want to talk about it, don't
want to comment about it, don't want to do nothing about it.
I've talked to Mr. Reynolds, I've talked to the district commissioner of district one,
Brian or whatever his name is, you know he's like you know what do you want me to do?
It's about our sewer bill, you know out there.
You know I talked to Ms. Watkins.
Ms. Watkins told me that you know there's, I'm in the wrong department to bitch about
this but you know I've been here for three or four hours so you're going to listen to
me.
You know I don't understand why nothing can be done about this.
You know we're sitting out there, our sewer bill has went from $47.50 to $57.50 to $60
to now $63.50 all in one year with no explanation.
Okay and the woman that is in charge of it and everything, Melanie Wood and everything,
you know I moved there five years ago.
My commode backed up four times within six months.
My builder dug up my yard three times and just like the lady told me with the high coal
utility told me you know until you prove that it's my fault I ain't going to do a D thing.
Live with it.
Come find out after three years, I mean three times my yard was dug up it was her fault.
Did she apologize to me?
No.
What she does is you know she don't send us any bills or anything.
The due date is on the 9th.
She sends our bills out, it gets to us on the 2nd, 3rd and 4th.
She charges us a late fee and everything.
Ain't nothing we can do.
She comes and cuts our, if you don't pay your bills she comes and cuts it off.
She shows up on a Friday evening at 7 o'clock at night, cuts it off.
You either got a thousand, fifteen hundred or two thousand whatever she feels like she
wants to do.
That's what you got to pay and then to cut it back on it's another thousand fifteen.
One person out there is up to twenty four thousand dollars.
Okay.
She does what she wants to do.
You know everybody I talk to don't nobody want to do nothing.
You know and I'm in the wrong place so like I said y'all won't hear me you know but if
it was in y'all's district I guarantee you'd do something about it without a doubt.
If it was in Tommy Battle district I'll hell break loose.
You know but uh you know I don't know what to do.
Hopefully I'm going to email Miss Watkins and see if she can help me and everything.
It seems like that you know she's kind of poor like me and everything and maybe she'll
get something done because I don't see anything unless it's a sidewalk Bill Kling will probably
do something.
Unless it's a backing in backwards or something in the space maybe Mr. Meredith or John Meredith
would do something about it.
Mr. Little I don't even know anything about you I don't ever hear anything about you.
You know Mr. Battle you know if it ain't about kneeling or taking statues away from us he
ain't going to do nothing about it.
I'm sorry sir your time is up.
The County Commission gives opportunities for public comment.
You might want to go share your comments at the County Commission meeting.
The next person is Christopher Lioi followed by Molly Kluck.
Good evening Christopher Lioi my address is on the sheet.
You're a resident of the city of Madison.
I'm here this evening because this week is the international BDS Boycott, Investment
and Sanctions campaign week of action against Elbit Systems a company which is represented
in Huntsville.
In order to hopefully begin what I hope and intend to be an ongoing public conversation
about an entity that even among the many morally dubious companies that are responsible for
this town's prosperity is a repeat offender in some very serious crimes.
Elbit Systems is an Israeli military contractor which after a series of mergers and acquisitions
has become as BDS calls it the cornerstone of the Israeli military industrial complex.
This subsidiary in the US, Elbit Systems of America has offices and production facilities
in several US states and a quick search shows that Alabama is the only state that has more
than one one of which is in Talladega one of which is right here in Huntsville just
north of Redstone Arsenal.
Most of the companies in and around the arsenal, Lockheed, Raytheon, all the rest of them,
the so-called defense contractors are no such thing.
They are war contractors.
These companies sell war.
Not bad enough, but Elbit Systems sells genocide.
Its business model may as well be we will sell you the tools to commit crimes against
humanity.
Its predecessors sold weapons to the South African apartheid regime in the 70s, to the
Guatemalan regime in the 80s that used them to massacre hundreds of thousands of indigenous
Mayan people.
In 2016 it sold weapons to the government of Myanmar despite the ICC's finding that
they were responsible for the genocide of the Rohingya people.
And of course it is responsible in large part for the weapons that have been used in the
genocide in Palestine.
And it's allowed a comfy office in a nice research park in the middle of Huntsville.
For quite a while there had been a community effort to try and get the city council to
pass a ceasefire resolution in Gaza.
You declined.
You declined even after months of publicly documented murder despite immediately passing
one in support of Israel in the wake of October 7th.
This is not an idle issue.
This is a public alignment of the city of Huntsville with the people who are responsible
for the destruction of an entire Mediterranean civilization.
I recognize having said that I'm not going to convince you to evict this company with
a single speech in a single meeting.
I just wanted to let you know that this is on our radar and that the consequences of
hosting a company like this, especially given the Iran war which is only getting more serious,
is only going to grow over time.
And just personally it annoys me that I have to come to these meetings that are invariably
open by Christian prayers, by people who ostensibly believe in the teachings of a man who said
blessed be the peacemakers, who cannot be bothered to even make tepid statements against
our own grotesque economy of war.
Thank you.
The next person will be Molly Cluck.
Molly Cluck will be followed by Thomas and you're going to have to excuse me, Carl Dolores.
My name is Molly Cluck.
My address is correct on the sheet and I'm a resident of Huntsville.
I grew up with the belief that this country was built on a promise, life, liberty and
the pursuit of happiness.
Yet what does that promise mean today when brown families live in fear of a knock at
the door, when people disappear into detention without due process, when enforcement agencies
act with a level of force that leaves communities shaken, grieving and distrustful?
When I've been here before, I've mentioned the people murdered by ICE early this year.
But just because the shootings happened back in January doesn't mean they aren't still
terrorizing people.
More recently, an ICE agent was charged with assault after pointing a gun at civilians
during a confrontation while driving a car.
These interactions are symptoms of a system that's not built to obtain its stated purpose
and constantly marches towards something colder and more indifferent.
People do not encounter the system and walk away untouched.
Families fracture, trust erodes, communities learn to live with a quiet and constant fear.
People act like it demonstrates strength to accept that fear is a cost of doing business.
But it's not strength, it's callousness.
And callousness left unchecked becomes something closer to nihilism, a belief that human dignity
no longer matters and that some lives are by nature of race or creed expendable.
Life, liberty, the pursuit of happiness.
If those words are going to mean anything at all, they must mean something here.
They must mean something now.
Because no one is free until we are all free.
That's not a slogan or some dumb talking point.
What it means is that if even one group can be denied safety, dignity, and due process,
then those rights are not secure for anyone here.
So the question before the City Council is not abstract.
It is immediate and it is local.
Will this city be complicit?
Will our resources, our law enforcement, our institutions be used to assist in actions
that undermine the very principles we claim to uphold?
Or will this City Council adopt a policy of non-cooperation with ICE?
No sharing of local data, no use of city personnel to assist federal immigration enforcement,
no participation in this ethnic cleansing which separates families and erodes civil
liberties.
Do not cooperate with injustice.
Do not normalize fear.
And do not stand by while the promise of this country is narrowed piece by piece until it
belongs to no one at all.
Make the decision, draw the line, and refuse cooperation with ICE.
Thank you.
We are now here from Thomas Clarus.
Writing wasn't real clear.
That's my best guess.
And we'll be followed by Howard Ross.
Thomas.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I yield my time.
So we will not have Mr. Clarus.
Now we will hear from Howard Ross.
Howard Ross will be followed by Forrest Satterfield.
Howard Ross, 2617 X Calabar Drive.
I'm following up from the last City Council meeting about the police allowed a trespasser
in at 601 6 Ellington Road and trying to find out how we can alleviate the situation and
brought in all the documents and trying to get a follow-up.
Is anyone going to do anything about it?
I guess it's in District 1.
And we don't know what to do about it.
We haven't heard back.
We got a call from HPD from Internal Affairs.
They said asked if we wanted to get the police officers in trouble who did it.
We said no, we just want to get the property back and get the house back and get the furnishings
back, trying to find out what we can do about that.
Is there anyone we can follow up with?
That's it.
Okay.
Mr. Riley, if you'll go with Mr. Ross out into the foyer, perhaps you could have a conversation
about it and give you an update.
Next we will hear from Mr. Forrest Satterfield followed by Taylor Miller.
All right.
Hello, y'all.
My name is Forrest Satterfield, 740 Constellation Place Drive, Huntsville, Alabama.
Thank you.
I was born in Huntsville Hospital and I volunteered at the Heart Center.
In fact, I became a biomedical engineer in part because Huntsville Hospital showed me
what healthcare could be.
I have real love for the Rockets City and for this institution.
If we do not address our current reality promptly, this crisis is going to get exponentially
worse.
We are caught in a healthcare death spiral.
Like ants trapped in an endless circular march, our healthcare system is exhausting itself
while going absolutely nowhere.
For patients, the distance to receive healthcare keeps growing, whether it's due to facility
closures or gridlock traffic.
Meanwhile, we are bleeding healthcare workers, why would new doctors or nurses move to North
Alabama when they are offered worse pay and grueling hours?
The healthcare workers that remain are burning out and leaving the profession entirely.
The result, we don't have anywhere near enough specialists.
If you are having a life-threatening emergency today, you might drive half an hour to the
local ER, wait for hours to be seen, only to be told you need a two-hour transfer to
Birmingham or Nashville to actually receive treatment.
We are not acting with the urgency this issue demands.
Huntsville Hospital recently paid $450 million to an out-of-state corporation to acquire
Crestwood Hospital.
Let me reiterate that.
We just sent nearly half a billion dollars to Tennessee in a move that does nothing to
fundamentally improve the care we receive.
I can't help but ask what could we have done with half a billion dollars if we had invested
it in our people?
We could have built new accessible facilities so we don't have to wait hours in the ER.
We could have attracted top-tier medical talent to North Alabama, and we could have supported
our existing healthcare workers who are already exhausted with the pay and resources they
deserve.
We have to stop prioritizing corporate consolidation and market monopolies over human lives.
It's time we return to the kind of patient care that inspires people to enter the medical
field in the first place.
Thank you.
We will now hear from Taylor Miller.
Taylor Miller will be followed by Susan Stewart.
Is Taylor Miller here?
Then we will move on to Susan Stewart who will be followed by Liliana Painter.
Hello, I'm Susan Stewart.
My address is correct on the sign-in sheet.
I live in Huntsville.
I got here too late to sign up for First Agenda, but I also came here to talk about healthcare
tonight instead of immigration.
Also be sure to look at that 85-year-old woman who was taken into custody by ICE in Alabama.
We made the national news again.
I'll be back to talk about that stuff later.
I'm wasting all my time.
In general, consolidations and mergers, whether they are media, newspapers, restaurant corporations,
and hospitals generally do not lead to an improvement in quality.
Generally there's a decrease in quality and accessibility.
But I actually had a chance to talk to Jeff Samms out in the hallway after he was in here.
I mainly talked to him about things based on my personal experience as an RN at Huntsville
Hospital.
I wanted to talk to him about the staffing, specifically the nurse-patient ratios, which
while they are at sort of the standard, are still below what the recommended levels are.
And I wanted to talk to him about the patient care techs, who we have difficulty retaining
because they could make more working at Walmart.
When I was there, they could make more at Walmart than as patient care techs.
Those folks that come into your room and bring you your soda and your sandwich in the middle
of the night, help you go to the bathroom, they're also checking your blood sugar.
They're checking your vital signs.
They are on the front lines and are often responsible for life and death decisions supporting
the nurses.
And the nurses can't do their jobs without it.
By the time I finished working at Huntsville Hospital, there was such a deficit of patient
care techs that I was terrified going into work every night that I would have patients
who weren't getting what they needed because I couldn't do it without them.
And I feel like this, what's going on here now with how huge Huntsville Hospital has
gotten and all the resources they have and looks like they're doing great financially,
that this really is a watershed moment.
It's an opportunity to do something about this, to increase our low pay across the region.
Nurses make more if they leave this area and they do leave this area.
So I asked him to use the leverage he has now as this giant mega health care corporation
to negotiate better rates as Councilmember Meredith suggested he might do and to get
better returns so they can increase the numbers of staff and increase the pay for those staff.
And to use his leverage then as this giant corporation to demand, I know it's a public
hospital, but anyway, to demand Medicaid expansion.
They had $172 million in unreimbursed patient care last year that gets spread out then among
the remaining patients and health care companies.
We really, really need this.
And those are only the numbers.
The human cost of the lack of expansion of Medicaid is something I saw every night when
I went into work.
And I wanted to ask you, please use your voices as elected officials to demand the same for
the people of Huntsville.
Thank you.
We'll now hear from Liliana Painter who will be followed by Nadia Pinder.
My name is Liliana Painter and I am a resident of Huntsville.
My address is correct on the sheet.
Good evening, Madam President and Council.
I appreciate the continued investment in community events across our city.
Tonight's agenda included a $15,000 allocation of council improvement funds in District 3
for an Independence Day celebration at Ditto Landing.
Just like this matter, they bring families together and strengthen community pride.
At the same time, I want to respectfully raise a broader question.
How are district level funding priorities determined?
Residents use Ditto Landing year round.
In addition to events, residents want to see practical improvements like bathrooms, dog
stations and possibly a pavilion so families can have more usable, comfortable space.
And on that note, I would also like to encourage us to think about shade and gathering spaces
at places like Weatherly Elementary where students and staff rely on a line of trees
closer to the road without fencing for coverage.
These are the kinds of everyday quality of life improvements residents notice.
Events are valuable, but long-term investments in safe, usable public spaces matter even
more.
As our city continues to grow, residents deserve a clearer way to understand how district funds
are allocated and how they can provide input on what their neighborhoods need most.
I share this in spirit of collaboration, transparency and building a stronger community.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
And I believe we're meeting tomorrow and we can talk more about that.
Nadia Pender, who will be followed by David Snyder.
Hello.
I live in Madison.
Sorry for the record, please.
Oh, Nadia Pender.
You're in the city of Madison.
Yeah.
Thank you.
All right.
I missed the first comments round.
I'm just going to say monopolies are bad.
I play Monopoly the game.
We know that monopolies are bad, so I don't really understand why something illegal is
happening in Huntsville.
I mean, multiple things.
I mean, ICE is here in Huntsville and I think that's just wrong.
And breaking a lot of constitutional rights, that's already illegal.
But why do we keep building on top of that, allowing monopolies and, you know, risking
healthcare patients and jobs and whatnot in Huntsville?
I mean, I'm disappointed that it's, you know, happening in Huntsville where I was born.
And I don't really have much to say besides that, besides, you know, ICE.
Get rid of ICE in Huntsville.
Thank you.
And we will conclude with David Snyder.
Hello.
My name is David Snyder.
My information is written correctly on the sheet.
And I live in Huntsville.
Thank you.
I would like to start by saying that I am humbled and awed once again by many of the
advocates and their skill and eloquence in their speeches that they've given.
I'm not sure why the tower is so high.
It's something to live up to.
But on 28th February, 2026, the first day of the, quote, 2026 Iran War, a girls' elementary
school in Manab province in southern Iran was destroyed by a missile strike.
According to witness accounts collaborated by satellite-based analysis, the area of the
school was hit by multiple strikes.
The roof of the school collapsed on students.
156 civilians were killed, including 120 school children.
As of the 15th of March, 2026, the attack was the deadliest strike in terms of civilian
casualties in the ongoing, quote, war.
So there are many things that I would like to talk about, many things that are happening
in the city, things that I'm trying to engage with several agencies right now, but nothing
is important to me as paying a bit of respect to these school children.
So for 120 seconds, one second representing every child, I will be taking a moment of
silence.
And, Mr. – and David, you are welcome to do that.
This is the time for your comments.
Do you have any further comments that you would like to make?
You have one minute and 30 seconds left for comments.
If you have no further comments, then your time is over.
Councilmembers, is there any more business to come before the council?
Move to adjourn.
If there are moved to adjourn, we are adjourned.
Thank you all.